so the other day you know I said that we
could uh start by talking about this
audio leak of Donald Trump that CNN put
out but I said you know the rule is you
gotta wait a couple days before you do
because the context will always change
the narrative was that Donald Trump was
caught on tape saying he had these
documents and they were classified
then the league comes out everybody
hears it the view and many others say
this is damning evidence Trump's going
to go to jail this is proof positive now
we're learning that the whole story was
a hoax sure the audio exists Donald
Trump was talking about declassifying
certain stories but it appears now that
Donald Trump wasn't actually holding
classified documents in the audio he was
talking about a news report that had
come out a few days earlier
and uh Trump is not being charged in
relation to anything having to do with
the Iran memo so the only thing we can
surmise Donald Trump is telling the
truth when he says in the recording when
you hear him flipping through papers
he's talking about a New Yorker story
and saying he should have Declassified
the Intel behind the story and the media
running with the lies so they say the
walls are closing in but they're not
it's all fake news so we'll talk about
that plus we got a whole bunch more news
Joe Biden's got dementia I guess he's
saying that uh Putin's losing the war in
Iraq I guess that makes sense
considering he doesn't have any any
divisions or battalions in Iraq so okay
I guess technically that's true and then
you've got uh Bud Lights and Anheuser
Bush's CEO coming out saying they're
actually paying Distributors now they're
giving money to them
they're effectively paying people to
carry their beer that's how bad things
have gotten because they're being hurt
by the boycott so we'll talk about all
those stories before we do my friends
head over to castbrew.com and buy cast
Brew Coffee to support our work at his
hour coffee company it is delicious I
gotta admit I think it's the best coffee
I've ever had and that makes sense
considering we actually got the samples
we tested them and we made them exactly
as we wanted it to be but I think you'll
get a kick out of I think it's really
really good coffee you're supporting us
you're supporting the parallel economy
you're supporting companies that don't
hate you go to casper.com join the cast
Brew Coffee Club you get three bags per
month or just come down here and choose
rise with Roberto Jr Appalachian nights
Columbia and French roast we got new
Blends coming soon we got K-Cups coming
soon in the next couple of weeks we're
gonna have our sleepy Joe and unwoke
decaf as well as I believe we're going
to be launching Mr boca's pumpkin spice
experience so again casper.com we're
sponsoring ourselves check it out also
head over to timcast.com click join us
become a member we're gonna have a
members only uncensored show for you
tonight at 10 p.m and this one is going
to be very very funny we already have
the story that we want to talk about and
uh well I don't want to say too much
because it's not for the kids it's not
for the families but it's a it's a very
very uh humorous story you may have seen
on Twitter pertaining to definitions
related to uh women and uh the woke are
getting some Flack for how they're
describing women once again and it's
it's actually kind of uh hilarious so
become a member you want to check that
one out and you can even call into the
show and talk to us and our guests if
you've been a member for at least six
months or sign up at the 25 per month
level so smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends joining us tonight to
talk about this and so much more is
Michael Seifert how's it going glad to
be here thanks for having me what do you
do my name is Michael Seifert I am the
founder and CEO of Public Square which
is proud supporter of this show and the
country and the Constitution and the
values that it protects we're the
nation's largest Marketplace of
businesses that do not hate you so if
you're a patriotic America American who
loves the Constitution and the values
that it protects we have over 55 000
businesses from all over the country
that have agreed with that set of values
and would love to serve you they give
you discounts for going there it's a
pretty cool Marketplace you can find it
at publicsq.com we launched Nationwide
just less than a year ago we've got over
a million consumer members on the
platform and glad to be here supporting
the parallel economy yeah absolutely man
we uh we think what you guys do is
absolutely fantastic thanks man so
everybody should download the Public
Square app if you haven't already so
that you can start supporting businesses
that don't hate you and uh we'll we'll
win that parallel economy so thanks for
having us yeah thank you Anna Claire
hanging out hi I'm Hannah Claire brimlow
I'm a writer for timcast.com
how you doing I am Phil Labonte lead
singer of All That Remains
anti-communist and counter-revolutionary
here with my friend Serge I should
introduce you I guess in between I'm
sorry this is occurring to me
nothing wrong with what you said yeah it
was fine uh I am surge.com I am ready to
start when you are Tim let's jump into
this story we saw this last night from
The View they say as mediaite reporting
lock him up already The View gets wild
as hosts suggest Trump selling documents
predict he gets 10 years in prison so I
want to give you this context first
here's what they say I mean short of
this judge fundamentally script the case
I don't see how he gets less than five
to ten years he's literally in this he
discusses the contents of classified
information with people without security
clearances and then acknowledges he
can't declassify since he's not
president Heavens they got him they got
him I knew that if we waited a day the
context around the leaked audio would
come out and it would debunk The
Narrative and low it has from CBS news
Iran memo not among the 31 records
underlying charges in Trump Federal
indictment it would seem that the
context around the story is actually
relatively clear Jack besobic tweets doj
claims Trump is on tape showing
classified docs on July 21st the docs
have never been found but six days
before on July 15th the New Yorker had
an article where Millie accused Trump of
wanting to strike Iran is it possible he
was just holding the article
Donald Trump had said that he had in his
documents newspaper clippings and other
things like that in the Audio I can
understand even I thought initially it
does sound like he's holding these
documents
Donald Trump said immediately of that
recording he's like these are magazine
clippings that these are these are
copies of news reports
now it's all started to become clear
Donald Trump did have classified uh
documents to some degree or whatever at
Mar-A-Lago this was in Bedminster they
didn't find the documents why would
Trump get rid of these but keep those it
makes no sense unless
Trump not being charged with the Iran
memo documents the uh the doj not
finding Iran memo documents a story
coming out about Millie and Donald Trump
saying he was holding the story yeah the
most likely outcome is that Trump is
sitting with this reporter and he's like
take a look at these papers you know
this is what they give me and he's
pointing to a story from the New Yorker
and he says I should have Declassified
this I can't now he wasn't talking about
classified documents he was saying the
proof behind the lies he could have
Declassified and debunked the story
so it would seem that everything they're
saying about locking up Trump once again
just another the walls are closing in
bombshell report all lies as predicted
didn't by the way the view like two days
ago in response to Hunter Biden's leaked
WhatsApp messages say that the true
story of Hunter Biden and his father Joe
Biden's corruption was a story of a
Father's Love for his son and overcoming
addiction so while that's their response
to blatant corruption that we're
actually seeing in leaked WhatsApp
messages where Hunter is literally
telling a Chinese official I'm sitting
here with my father send us the money
that gets released and instead The View
jumps on this story without the facts it
all crumbles as it always does and we
play the same reel over and over and
over again let's look I want to pull up
the document from the Trump indictment
take a look at this this is how corrupt
the doj is
they say that uh Trump will no longer
was president gave an interview at the
office of Bedminster blah blah blah he
was recorded with Trump's knowledge and
consent before the interview the media
published reports at the end of Trump's
term a senior military official
purportedly feared that Trump might
order attack on Country a take a look at
Trump's quote we now know senior
military official is Millie We Know
Country a is Iran it's he said Trump
said well with Millie let me see that
I'll show you an example he said that I
wanted to attack Iran isn't it amazing
if Donald Trump was holding a classified
document the document would not read
Millie accuses Trump of wanting to
attack Iran it would say proposal for
Attack on Iran or Donald Trump you know
it always reasons not to yeah yeah I
would say like it would be a document
explaining instead Trump says I'll show
you an example he said I wanted to
attack Iran and then you have the New
Yorker story Millie says Trump wanted to
attack Iran it is it is actually kind of
clear based on what Trump said
he's talking about a news report and
just lying about everything and here
here we are once again having to call
this out now look I'll say this it's
entirely possible I'll always I'll
always it's not absolute maybe this goes
to court and they're like no actually it
really was a document but they have no
document they found no document Trump
says there was no document the story
just come on this is insane
yeah sometimes you have to take the
simplest explanation which is that the
left-wing media wants Trump to be a
terrible person and I think obviously
without context you can frame anything
anybody says to give it a negative light
but in this case all you needed was very
slight information to make it clear what
was going on the way I describe it is
like imagine there's some kid playing
Grand Theft Auto
and he's talking about his plans
and then that you you take a quote a
recording of a kid playing GTA and it
will sound like this kid's like going to
be a manager like a maniac talking about
stealing cars and kidnapping people and
you're like oh man someone's got to stop
this kid and then you go to his room and
it's just some some 12 year old kid
playing GTA this is basically what they
do because no one can see what Trump is
actually doing they twist the context
listen to the paperwork Trump's saying
he could Declassified these papers he
was talking about the story behind the
story yeah the documents behind the
story could have been Declassified he
can't do it now because he's on an
office he doesn't have the documents
anymore
I was just gonna say well the problem
even for the left that loves to jump on
any stuff like this it's the boy who
cried wolf at this point so everybody's
assumption anytime anything like this
gets quote unquote exposed is that
it's just another bureaucratic nonsense
the left's coming after Trump and Trump
probably didn't actually do anything
that was wrong and this is another one
of those examples where it looks
potentially bad because they're only
revealing part of the story and so part
of the problem is nobody trusts our
institutions anymore so it's the same
thing now we're seeing with actual
corruption with the president that's in
office to be fair can we really call The
View our institution
that's a group of empty-headed people
yes but it's been around for a long time
a lot of people watch it I think I'm not
totally sure there are a lot of wine
moms that have nothing to do and that's
where they're getting their information
so now they're hearing that Trump
obviously a hundred percent did terrible
thing and they won't look for the Nuance
I think that's the biggest thing white
women Must Be Stopped we're crazy what
can I say can I play this 20-second clip
from Family Guy to help you guys
understand the view uh this is important
context and I'm providing commentary on
this clip so I want you all to uh to
watch this clip
uh can we get the audio Yeah audio's on
the wrong Channel
hey Stewie three o'clock time for The
View no no no not again
oh my God
[Laughter]
yeah let me out of here I can't watch
another second so my favorite part of
the gag is when the woman bucks and then
she gets up and there's an egg and the
camera Zooms in on the egg very very
well done joke Family Guy that's
basically what the view is so uh
FairPoint Phil we can't call the view
one of our institutions but it is sad
that all of our actual institutions
don't look that different than the view
New York Times is posting pretty much
the same content the doj says the same
thing the view says on the same days
it's insane you're you're 100 right and
it's something that I've talked about
before is is you'll know it's not just
something like the view in the New York
Times it goes to Teen Vogue so it's like
not just about one narrative coming from
one perspective or whatever why would
Teen Vogue have the same kind of stories
that GQ runs yeah and they really do
they all come from the same perspective
but hold on remember when Teen Vogue ran
that like Mark's puff piece yeah yeah
like what's going on at Teen Vogue
Connie's everywhere team Vogue ran a
what to do to help your friend who just
had an abortion and they suggested you
get funny movies and pins that support
Planned Parenthood team Vogue is a
classic they're really helpful and
they're helping but but they they pass
it off as well we are making news
palatable to younger readers so we can
raise more informed people but we only
want them to be informed in our
perspective and that's effectively what
all these institutions do right they
they don't want you to follow no one is
going to issue a correction the view is
not going to come out and be like turns
out there was more context you know we
we jump to conclusions they're just
gonna pretend like they were right all
along or like this never happened until
they think they have some sort of actual
evidence I mean compare this leaked
audio to actual WhatsApp messages one is
clear and one is taken out of context
and they're just they're literally I
mean thirsty for for just a drop of of
something to some way to cast Trump as
the bad guy well and they the problem
with what that that exact scenario just
laid out is that anybody that actually
reports the WhatsApp messages with
Hunter Biden is now labeled conservative
media right so it's like no no we're not
conservative media this is just
objectively what happened the vice
president's son is literally texting
this Chinese official saying we've got
your money if you're but now if you
report that your scene is right wing so
like I know people real well in my life
that were like 80s Blue Dog Democrats
that were taught to trust our
institutions you listen to CNN you watch
these shows you read Time Magazine and
that support supposed to be the reliable
forms well now anytime anybody's
reporting the truth they write it off
because it's like well no that's
conservative right wing news and I don't
you know I don't want to get involved in
the political divide so they just take
whatever the regime is saying because
they have these mouthpieces and they
never actually get exposed to the truth
that's why when you tell people like hey
Biden actually said this they're like
nah that wouldn't be real or else I
would have known about it there's
there's a lot of that going on there's
and it's been going on for a long time
when when I think it was 2000
18 or something like that I and I was
talking about Biden had said uh that
there that he was going to come after
rifles there were AKs and and then
AR-15s and friends of mine that are you
know pretty left-leaning we're swearing
up and down no they don't no they don't
no he didn't and I'm like I literally
had to send them links and they're like
they actually had to be like wow okay
well that's a terrible idea for him to
say that because he's gonna I'm like
well yeah but it's you don't know even
what the people that you ostensibly are
going to be voting for are saying so
where do you you know how can you
consider yourself an informed voter so
do you have a moment where you stop
trusting the media like do you remember
oh yeah but it was a long time ago how
was it tell me a yellow cake what was
that yellow cake uranium in in Iraq that
was when I was like okay because
initially like when I was young I I kind
of thought Bill Clinton was cool he you
know he played sax and smoked pot and I
was like yeah that was my you know I was
a kid and so I thought he was all right
and then when when uh when it came out
that he had you know lied under oath and
stuff and impeachment I figured that he
was going to get removed from office
because the president's supposed to be
held to higher standards and then when
he wasn't I was like oh well then that
means that and this is a simple minded
take I understand but I was young that
means the Democrats are the lying party
and the Republicans are the party that
tells the truth and then we went to you
know eight years later we were in Iraq
and I'm like wait a minute they both lie
so I can't trust any of them and the
media had sold both of them as as
acceptable arguments and I I just felt
like they're and unfortunately the
libertarian party is the party where the
guy takes his pants off on stage
the kids or walks around with a boot on
his head no that's a Democrat he
probably actually runs Supreme yeah he
hangs out with the Libertarians now yeah
but he runs as a Democrat oh thank God
like you know it's it's not fair to
include the satirical candidate into the
legitimate libertarian party candidates
who actually have taken their clothes
off on stage and advocate for selling
drugs to kids so but the libertarian
party has improved dramatically with the
mises caucus so we're big fans of those
guys and there are much more serious
political party now so we'll see how
that you know how that plays out it's
gonna be interesting I mean um let's
jump to this story first I was I was
gonna pull up a different story but
let's pull this one up from Rasmussen 35
of Democrats think RFK JR could win the
latest respiration report national
telephone and online survey found 49 of
likely as voters have a favorable
impression of RFK Jr including 14 with a
very favorable opinion 38 view Kennedy
unfavorably including 18 with a very
unfavorable impression while another 14
are not sure so uh this is it you know
we're not we're not we don't have the
rest of the data that's that's the
general idea right here
RFK Junior's polling in the double
digits we're seeing something
interesting a lot of people have
suggested this could be our last
election both on the left and the right
or maybe
2020 was our last
sort of election I guess with ballot
harvesting and all the rules being
changed and all the and coveted lockdown
can you really even call it maybe 2016
was the last because whatever's gonna
coming up in 2024 it'll approximate an
election yeah like 2020 did but it's
going to be very very weird so there
will be something but you're gonna have
what RFK Jr Trump who I mean who who are
the candidates going to be the fact is
the Santa's people don't want to vote
Trump trump people don't want to vote to
Santas they are fighting to an extreme
degree you've got the media smearing RFK
Junior to an extreme degree but he's
pulling in double digits near 20 is
consistently around 20 it seems like the
system's starting to fracture in a bunch
of different ways so it's hard to know
exactly who's going to win but I did see
another poll that said Democrats are
more likely to vote third party than
Republicans which suggests a trump
Victory because if RFK Jr runs an
independent you know not getting the
Democratic nomination or if they put
Biden in it's it then it will split the
Democrat vote yeah do you think RFK Jr
would run as independent or will they
pull a Bernie there's all kinds of
reports that he's considering running
independent he hasn't told me personally
what he's gonna do but he might as well
I mean he has so much uh momentum
there's no reason if he has the funding
there's no reason for him not to and do
you think the Democrats would let him
touch the debate stage no you don't
think so no of course not I mean look
they cut Andrew Yang's microphone yeah I
remember that sir that was hilarious I
mean you can't put Biden on a debate
statement there's no way that he would
be able I mean already I'm trying to
find the numbers right now but uh a
significant number of Democrats
Democrats Phil Biden is too old so yes
there's infighting the Republicans but
the Democrats don't want their most
likely uh incumbent nominee right now I
mean this is not looking good for me and
I'm not uh a political consultant by any
means but RFK can only benefit even if
he doesn't end up being the Democratic
nominee why not just push forward so
many moderates are looking at him like
Hey this guy's interesting the same way
that there were moderates who didn't
think of themselves as any particular
party who ended up voting for Trump
because they felt like he represented
something I think RFK in some way could
win ground back for the Democrats not
every single one but I think that he
represents something the Democrats
haven't had in a long time there's a lot
of Boomers I think that would would that
would appeal to him or that would he
would appeal to just because of the fact
that he's a Kennedy uh Adrian Curry made
this great or called him this great
thing and I I picked up from her that
the son of Camelot there's a lot of
people that are older that are older Gen
X and and Boomers that still hearken
back to that you know the Camelot era
the the way that they looked at uh the
Kennedys and and all that stuff and a
lot of the stuff that he's saying is the
stuff that people that are fairly
anti-government get into even he's got a
lot of influence even in the libertarian
party
um which personally I don't understand
it so much other than his anti-wars and
anti like kind of pharmaceutical stance
um or at least skepticism but I do think
that he would appeal to a significant
portion of the older Democrats yeah he
doesn't have the same Progressive Edge
in some ways I mean look at what's going
on right now he is spending all of his
time in New Hampshire he's focused there
where is Biden going to concentrate
South Carolina the Democratic the the D
Triple C is already saying we want South
Carolina to primary first and this is
really upsetting New Hampshire's voters
and they they are saying you are going
to give the states to Republicans
obviously they don't carry a lot of
electoral votes on the other hand they
are traditionally the first in the
nation so Kennedy saying I'm going to
focus on you guys you are the state that
I I will pay attention to shows uh an
interest in keeping with some traditions
and some balances of power that the
Biden wing of the Democrat Party is
willing to abandon what if it is RFK I
mean you look Biden can't campaign he
can't travel around the country no I
mean the the big news which we'll get
into in a second is that he's got CPAP
marks on his face now he's 80 years old
the dude is unwell and we've known he's
been he's got metal plates in his head
he can't talk straight he can't travel
around this country RFK Junior Canada
what is he 69 years old yeah he's also
fit got that video of him you know doing
the his lift bench press bench pressing
yeah and uh
he's going to be able to go around and
get votes he's gonna be able to build
his profile he does have a difficult
time speaking though with all due
respect and and that matters but he's
still been able to he's still going to
be able to get those ideas across he's
still gonna be able to go on podcasts do
Town Halls Biden cannot
I think how could Gavin Newsom beat
someone like RFK Jr true and I think
even with I'm not sure what to call it
maybe a speech impediment with the RFK
has you you hear it once you get used to
it with Biden he just yeah doesn't have
any actual cohesive thoughts I mean
there is there is not it would be
terrifying to put him on it yeah he
doesn't have a speech impediment the
lights are literally out whereas RFK
junior is a really smart guy but do you
you know Tucker last night came out and
basically made the prediction on his
Twitter show that it's going to be Gavin
Newsom and as a California that scares
me uh to death like you you think you
think RFK JR could be Gavin yes really
absolutely okay I mean isn't uh do you
think the establishment
well no no no I'm saying if you were to
places yeah if you put Gavin Newsom on
stage with RFK Jr Jr wins no question I
totally agree now whether or not the
establishment the machine the media
would allow something like that to
happen is an entirely different question
yeah yeah so uh but I think in terms of
I think Trump would have a hard time
debating RFK Jr yeah RK Jr is doing a
fantastic job he's got he's got Trump
supporters being like we like this guy
and people actually saying Trump RFK Jr
or Trump Kennedy is the ticket yeah I
mean it should be legendary yeah I mean
seriously yeah massive yeah I I mean
that'd be great if elon's right about it
being like the funniest outcome being
the most likely then then bring it on
then Trump Kennedy well he he got that
Twitter spaces where he had uh Kelly
Slater on it Tulsi gabbard like all of
these people that sort of represent this
anti-establishment Wing that's not even
tied to a political party it's just a
cultural sentiment happening so when you
have the best surfer in the world that's
getting like Twitter spaces yeah dude he
was on the he was invited to the spaces
and so when you have the best surfer in
the world like backing a political
candidate and then Jack Dorsey comes out
and offers that support too so it's a
very interesting Coalition he's building
and uh it is interesting though you go
back to the libertarian side of him that
on issues like Pharmaceuticals he is pro
2A at least he says but then he's hype
not always and they're old lips that are
coming out now where he's like okay dude
but on top of that like he's super big
government on issues of environmentalism
it's like okay so are you a green New
Deal president because that's yeah he
probably is and there are a lot of
people who are probably saying yes I
want that there are probably a lot of
Democrats who know that Biden can't win
and absolutely would vote for off Cajun
you're probably older ones the younger
ones they just believe whatever they
hear in the median it's laughably sad
not all of them but a lot of them it is
a kind of weird thing right you find
like older Democrats won't believe you
when you tell them what the media says
and younger Democrats believe whatever
the media says they were raised on TV
their parents have been putting them in
front of the TV they just trusted it's
like having another adult in their lives
uh I also think they have made it so
distrusting the media is a right-wing
thing and so if it's trendy to be
left-wing you can't uh well that's what
you don't have to trust that's what you
were saying if if uh Joe Biden
hypothetically is in his bathroom and
stumbles out of the shower to grab his
dog's tail and then breaks his ankle if
you report that in any way that's
negative they'll call you right wing
I was like but that's that's the thing
that happened you know yeah and by the
way shouldn't shouldn't everybody be
concerned about his age if he were to
run again he played 85 at the end of his
next term so it's no way he can run no
he's going to beat his own record as the
nation's oldest president yeah but but
we've long speculated that they will
criminally charge Joe Biden he will get
indicted and he will get arrested maybe
on the documents maybe on the corruption
and then they'll say we're not biased
we're going after Trump and Joe Biden
clearing the way for someone like
Newsome 538 has them at a
54.8 percent disapproval rating right
now in a 4 out of 10 approval wow so
it's like historically bad it's like I
think only only behind a Carter right I
mean it's it's awful and it's been awful
all the time and he's not doing anything
to make it better I mean right now he's
on his tour about broadband internet
which is interesting and great but you
actually can't have him talk at all
because and this feels so distrustful to
say but he is ill he is not okay he is
not okay
even with uh uh which should be a slam
dunk this Broadband tour you know he he
can't win support because the more he's
in public the more people become
concerned I think that part of the
reason I think I don't think that that's
a compelling issue for the American
people like I don't think you really
think
especially covid there were so many
rural communities that struggled what
everyone else said you can just do
things online and communities like it's
like I think of West Virginia and all
the mountains like you could could not
have school online because there is not
there are communities that don't have
internet at home and we and it took us
six months to get internet yeah both
locations it's insane and it cost tens
of thousands of dollars to get them to
actually trench and then lay the lines
down to the to the note or whatever it
was nuts I'm not saying it's like the
single biggest issue
leave your state that wants to develop
business I mean you might be able to
speak to this more but
if you're trying to lure young people in
you're saying oh you can work remotely
now well then you need guaranteed solid
internet access so it's not enough to
have affordable housing or people who I
land like if you cannot work from home
then the idea that you would move to a
rural State like West Virginia Maine
Wyoming to a certain extent I feel like
there are I feel like there are issues
that are more motivating that are more
top of mind I'm not saying it's the only
issue I'm just saying I think it does
make a big difference especially in the
post-covet era because I feel like
people now now are still feeling
pressures from uh inflation and I do
think that one of the things that's most
most saline most pressing on people's
minds is the stuff with the with LG with
this year's pride month yeah in June in
particular yeah again like I said I was
I was out in California a couple weeks
ago talking to my friends that are not
uh you know super politically active and
they are talking about the you know the
things that are going on in schools and
stuff that's going on at Target and
that's something because it's it deals
with kids and parents are laser focused
on the thing that is going to most make
them anxious or concerned about their
kids and I think that that kind of stuff
is the stuff that if he were going to be
able to produce a compelling message
that
could help his his numbers I feel like
that's where it would be and I don't
think that he is in us in a place where
or I don't think the Democrats at all
are in a place where they could actually
say look we do condemn these types of
things and I think that that's probably
one of the reasons why he's got such bad
poll numbers I think ladies and
gentlemen I think Joe Biden may be not
long for this world and it breaks my
heart it breaks my heart
um look we know the guy's 80 and these
photos have emerged showing strange
markings on his face
the guy's 80 we know he's got health
issues he's already passed the life
expectancy for the average U.S male I
think it's like 79 years old this he's
80 now I believe right so these images
pop up showing these marks on his face
and of course every everyone is
concerned as to what this may be the
media is reporting that he is now using
a CPAP machine because he suffers from
sleep apnea I believe they're lying I
believe what's more likely is that he's
an old man he's probably on oxygen
they're probably supplementing him and
they use they're probably using these
bands as a way to obfuscate what's
actually going on with his ailing with
his failing body they claimed that his
his gaffes speech impediment no he
doesn't have one he's never you listen
to him talking in the 90s he was
speaking just fine
then they say Obama was younger he did
and that is now that he's getting older
it's coming back no he's just he's
getting older that's just it sure it's
fine call whatever you want it's still
because of age right the argue the
argument they're making is oh he's
getting older so now it's coming back
well yeah the point of making a comment
about the stutter is because of his age
that's that's ridiculous but take a look
at this I mean he's got these these
markings on both sides of his face and
you know look
how long do those markings stay pressed
into his face did he did he wake up
literally right before he went out for
his flight took off the mask and had the
marks on his face the dude is is unwell
so in speaking about whether or not he
can run in 2024 I don't think there's a
question he can't yeah no he really
can't well and I think your strongest
case for the oxygen argument is that
it's almost it almost looks like any
moment he's not in front of people he
has to have something strapped he's got
that he's got IV marks on his hands at
one point exactly and I'll stress this
they mentioned that uh let me let me
pull the caption
his sleep apnea has been public
knowledge since 2008. and he wasn't
using a CPAP machine only now he is I
don't buy it no no also people who sleep
apnea wear it while they're sleeping
from what I understand not while they're
just sitting at their desk in their
office yes well this is a picture from
him in the morning about to get on some
plane but the question is did he just
wake up he's wearing a suit how long did
it take him to put that suit on and how
long would those markings stay on your
face I can't I can't imagine they'd
stand his face that long his suit
actually goes on like the Iron Man suit
just stand him up and the stuff just
gets thrown on him yeah I mean part of
what's happening with Biden I have
always found it annoying that the
mainstream media treats it like it's
super normal that he spends basically
all of his weekends at one of his two
private residences uh and that the White
House made this big shot at being like
we're so transparent here are the White
House visitor logs but we don't know who
goes to his house in Delaware you can
make an argument privacy should he be
allowed to whatever but it seemed clear
to me and again this is my personal
speculation that he is receiving
receiving some kind of medical treatment
when he goes home to Delaware on the
weekends because he was always I mean
even if he wasn't full on sick he's
always been getting older I mean he was
the oldest person elected president and
this has only continued to be true as he
has aged uh it seems like maybe things
are getting worse I it's hard to tell uh
but it feels to me like we're getting
more and more gaps now we're seeing
these markings it's only a matter of
time and I mean it's a good bet it's a
good bet and for me I kept saying when
is he going to announce that he's
running for reelection because his press
secretary seem to be hesitant even when
he was saying yes I will run and I think
that should tell you that the people
around him don't think he should
continue forward even if he himself
feels like there's no problem and maybe
he's not in a position to make that call
you know I don't think he is here was
the other story from around the same
time they say uh president 80 says Putin
is clearly losing the war in Iraq while
clutching notes on Wagner Uprising and
yet another blunder yet another blunder
and look in this store you can see the
marks on his face cheat sheet
this dude can't handle it man
he never could handle it
no and at this point too it's it's
really frustrating because
I remember when they used to say Trump
goes to Mar-A-Lago too much or it golfs
too much I should say and uh they
criticized DeSantis for being on
potentially ozempic and RFK Juniors on
testosterone and so all the things that
we should all be talking about with
Biden he gets a free pass he gets a free
pass to potentially be using drugs to
keep him awake at day he has gets a free
pass to not medically disclose to us
what he's actually doing that's keeping
him alive and somewhat sentient he
doesn't get criticized for going to
Delaware every seeming weekend he he
vacations more than any president we've
had in the last 40 years and he gets a
free pass for all of it so it's really
frustrating because it just feels like
we're all ignoring this massive elephant
in the room we're not obviously but a
lot of the country is and my greatest
fear that would cause me to really be
disappointed in our country and its
current state would be that if he
actually does run again and were to
somehow get reelected I think it would
be a massive indictment of our country
my biggest problem with what you're with
I I'm in agreement with you but my
biggest problem is the fact that the
American people I think are generally
aware of Biden's problems the at least
people that that actually are
politically aware that pay attention and
to you know enough to vote and stuff and
their ex they accept the obvious fact
that it is not the president that's
making the calls that means it is
someone else or it is a group of people
it's probably you know his advisors that
get together and make a you know make a
decision and tell him well Mr President
we're gonna do this because blah blah
blah and the fact that the American
people are comfortable with that to me
is a problem yeah we've gotten so
comfortable with the bureaucratic state
that we just don't even expect the
president to lead anymore and the one of
the biggest problems is that you don't
ever have anyone that's accountable when
the Situation's like this if there's
multiple bureaucrats that are making
decisions at the end of the day really
the ones making the decisions they will
never ever pay for any bad decisions
they will stay in office a lot of the
people that are still in the in the
Biden Administration are people that
were in the administration of George
Bush when we went into Iraq a lot of the
same players are still in Washington DC
in the you know in the quote-unquote
Deep state so you're not going to get
any kind of significant change until you
address that problem yeah well I think
it's another sign of that is that there
used to be a day in geopolitical
environments when like if you had a
president that had a gaffe like this
about major geopolitical actors like the
world would stand on notice because oh
my gosh the president of the Free World
just said something that about another
political leader related to war like
everybody used to really pay attention
and care and now it's like even the
other foreign leaders are like oh it's
another Tuesday with a gaffe and we
could call for war and no one would even
really do seriously we brought this up
when he was talking about Syria but kept
saying Libya yeah exactly and he kept
saying Libby over and over again and the
media of course downplayed saying oh
it's no big deal it is a big deal if he
goes to his generals and says I want to
see some territorial gains in Libya and
they go you got it next thing you know
it's like why is there a no-fly zone in
Libya it's like well Biden made a
mistake so what are the generals
supposed to do defy his orders
this is the this is this is the
conundrum yes we know he's not well in
the in in the mind and he's he said the
wrong word I think the average person
can assume he did not mean Libya is it
what if he did yeah are the generals
going to be alike sir are you sure and
he's like yeah you know of course come
on man you know I'm talking about like
okay or do they just say no he's he's
incapacitated so we're going to defy his
orders and ignore him well that goes
back to your point it's like I don't
even know who's in charge of the
generals at this point yeah how do they
make decisions you really think they ask
him for military strategy who knows like
no way I think it was Andy card I think
is his is his chief of staff or
something like that I'm not sure the the
chief of staff but that it may be just a
name that I'm remembering but I'm sure
that it's not Joe Biden yeah you know
it's just it's it's a council or I'm not
one of the guys that thinks that you
know Barack Obama's running stuff from
behind the scenes there are people that
make those kind of remarks I don't think
that's the situation I think it's just
people that are high up in the in the
administration that are the bureaucratic
you know I I think it's Joe Biden and I
think Afghanistan is proof you think
it's him you think he's made look at
Afghanistan any any sane person
who sat down you could take your average
middle-aged overweight American Dad sit
him not in the situation room and say
here's Afghanistan
we want to get out and that person would
do a better job that's true that's a
good point so I I wonder if like the
abandoning Bagram Air Force Base not
notifying the Afghan Afghani Security
Forces everything they did every error
it was insane how bad it was it was pure
chaos so it could be that there is no
leadership at all so people are doing
random things but considering the they
that the U.S abandoned that we the U.S
abandoned the Bagram Air Force Base
I kind of feel like that was a
leadership call from someone who is not
right in the head
Joe Biden and we got we got to get our
troops out of there man you know not not
September we're gonna get out of there
like okay well where should we draw get
them out of the air just get them out
get him out of the Air Force Base get
them up I wanted to withdraw them by the
anniversary of September 11th right he
made it in an emotional place instead of
following a tactical argument I was
shocked if he if he was that uh that
that Hands-On with with how the with how
do you explain it I I don't have a
better explanation but I would be very
surprised if President Joe Biden was
that Hands-On about how to carry out the
withdrawal because the you know I too
agree that it was ridiculous to have the
you know the combat troops come out
before the civilians absolutely and
abandoning the Air Force yes where are
you leaving all of our gear yeah where
you could get them out yeah I am why I'm
out of the Air Force Base I am as
flabbergasted as you guys are that that
was the actual process us that when that
actually happened I just would be really
surprised if Joe Biden was was you know
that granular about about commanding but
that's the point he wasn't
he's like hey we're going to get our
troops out of there and it's like well
look Mr President we've got an Air Force
Base we can't just get him out of the
Air Force Base then are you sure yeah
like oh whatever you say sir and I
always wonder if the generals that
received those orders are also as
incompetent or nefarial come on look at
Millie exactly that's where it's like I
don't I I wonder if it's literally just
a comedy of errors across the entire
leadership of the US government our
intelligence sucks if you were naive
enough to believe that Afghani officials
and forces there could hold that region
and then it fell in a matter of days
like how do you get things that wrong
across an entire organization as large
and profound as the US Military
it's a comedy bears and I always
struggle with how much do you attribute
to malicious intent versus incompetence
that is always a tough thing for me but
sometimes it's both yeah I think in this
case it was and I think in most things
happening in our government right now
there's a small faction of people that
are genuinely evil and then the rest of
the the people in The Nut House are just
pure incompetence at the highest degree
it's the people to judge that have no
ability or uh resume to lead
Transportation mayor of a nothing town
in Indiana doing wrong South Bend's fine
but like what what do you even have
public transportation and you're leading
this like our whole government in the
bureaucratic State at this point is this
massive hodgepodge uh collaboration
between malicious intent evil actors and
incompetence at the highest level and
ultimately I think that's why like
anybody that's even remotely normal and
is able to present any sort of sense of
leadership is rising to the top of the
cultural conversation Let's uh let's
jump to the cultural conversation
we got the story from CBS News
Anheuser-Busch CEO Brendan Whitworth
says financial assistance is being sent
to wholesalers beer distributors
impacted by boycott backlash let me
provide an alternate context for what
this information is first we'll take the
neutral approach the Anheuser CEO states
that they are giving money to people who
carry their beer let me make a little
more a little bit more hyperbolic for
you the boycott was so effective that
Bud Light now has to pay people to carry
its beer
because let's ask this question why
would Anheuser-Busch send financial
assistance to wholesalers and
distributors
these Distributors could simply just I
don't know carry different beers like
shift their business reduce uh their
their Workforce say we're going to get
off Bud Light no this is an Ezra Bush
saying we're going to pay you to keep
operating at this level
because we're going to try and pull out
of this one otherwise the wholesalers
say see you later the boycott has gotten
so bad that they are now paying people
to carry their beer no yeah and a job
yeah it's it's incredible to watch
actually and on our app the day after
Bud Light that ad campaign was released
with Dylan Mulvaney we saw an 800
increase in searches for beer on the
platform because people are tired of it
they're actually looking for their
options now Modelo is the top beer above
above Bud Light and it was funny because
some of the media tried to paint it as
like well that's because people are done
with domestic beer that's why that's why
bud light's tanked and it's like dude
all these other domestic beers have
actually risen in value this is exactly
and so uh you know what's interesting in
all this is that we don't think much
about how the actions of that man and uh
the CEO of Anheuser-Busch if you can't
see the screen
um and his cronies and the ad campaign
agency out of San Francisco how much
that actually negatively impacted the
people caught in the crossfire of all of
this which is like the Distributors the
middlemen the sales people like they
absolutely got screwed because you
cannot sell this beer anymore have you
ever seen The Dark Knight oh yeah you
guys you guys have seen that one right
absolutely I love the fan theory that
the Joker's actually the good guy right
and the reason is by the end of the
movie he's gotten rid of a dangerous
vigilante Batman Batman retires he's
gotten rid of the mob and all the
criminals what the Joker did throughout
that that movie destroyed the the
organized crime in the city and
destroyed the Vigilante fighting it it's
crazy and then in the next movie it's
like he's been retired for a couple
decades I bring this up because what if
this Anheuser-Busch CEO is actually just
that
he looks like the bad guy but deep down
he was sitting at his office and he was
looking at all the ESG and woke stuff
and he's like the only way this changes
is if someone pushes it over the top and
then a single tear rolls down his cheek
and he's like I will do the right thing
he gets on his phone and he's like Dylan
Mulvaney and he's like we've got a job
to do and uh because because in this
interview apparently the Anheuser-Busch
CEO has not ruled out hiring Dylan
Mulvaney in the future yeah it's absurd
and has doubled down on pride and has
said they will continue and they have
always been big supporters of this stuff
when your customers tell you we won't
buy your stock we won't buy your beer
and we will advocate for everyone not to
buy your beer to the point where you
have to pay Wholesales and Distributors
money to keep keep up their operations
you'd think at that point you'd be like
we're going to listen to our customers
and get away from this stuff we're sorry
he won't do it no we'll work kind of
through the guild card he's like I'm
really sad because it really impacts the
employees who've been working they have
pride in this you know 165 year old
company that's been around forever like
he is trying to say people boycotting
this beer are the ones hurting these
people who work in their you know
breweries or whatever and it's like you
made this call you're not taking any
personal responsibility in fact you seem
to be willing to risk their jobs again
it's crazy well yeah his doubling down
is a controlled demolition like if he
actually feels bad for his employees he
has single-handedly caused that problem
by the way like I run a company you run
a company if something bad happens in
the company It ultimately at the end of
the day is is your fault because we take
responsibility for the company because
the buck stops with us this has been the
exact opposite blaming your consumers
for pain that's been put on your
employees rather than taking
responsibilities like the most low life
thing that I've ever seen a company
executive do the target scene is doing
the same thing right now and now for you
to paper over it with this house of
cards sham organization you've created
by having to literally do a rebate
program and pay people to buy the beer
just propping up the house of cards
further I have never seen anything like
it plus uh to your theory he was former
CIA and they specialize in regime change
so if he is
elk regime maybe that is his ultimate
goal because it across the board has
decimated these World Companies 50
billion dollars of market cap dropped
just between Anheuser-Busch Disney and
Target alone in the past two months so I
I have never seen a more suicidal
campaign from a company than doubling
down what about Public Square what are
you guys seeing uh the opposite well
yeah that 50 billion dollars has to go
somewhere like that's the interesting
thing is that these boycotts are only
effective if you can ultimately shift
your lifestyle spending away to
something else which is why we exist so
we created the app so that if you're
tired of Bud Light if you're tired of
Target you can actually go to something
else so that's why when Bud Light
toppled uh we actually 27 billion
dollars of market cap dropped we saw an
800 increase in beer when Target came
out and did what they did we released a
Target Shopping Guide that actually
drove our app to top five apps in the
entire app store for a week across all
genres so anytime one of these cultural
mediums for Commerce decides to be
insane we're trying to be there to clean
up the mess and provide an alternative
so you can actually shift your spinning
away and what's happened is we've had
some people that said you know I said
that I was not going to go to Target for
June but I just couldn't imagine getting
Target away from my life in its entirety
and now they're saying I'm actually
finding my toilet paper paper towels
household cleaning products on Public
Square and I don't even need to do this
anymore and we have people asking us can
you open retail stores can we have this
literally be a replacement from Target
so that's where we're going but I think
the success of Public Square is a sign
of two things one is that the boycotts
are working and that people are tired of
woke Capital that's number one number
two is that people are actually hopeful
enough to go the extra mile to do
something different because the worst
indictment of our country and the
economic state currently would be that
if people either just kept shopping at
these companies even though they hated
them and these companies obviously hate
us in return or the other thing which is
that these people basically you know
boycott for a week and then lay off
because we don't have any other options
neither of those things are happening
people are actually shifting their
spinning away and this is is actually
working which is pretty incredible to
watch I think but Bud Light this is what
I made the joke about this guy being the
secret hero because what Bud Light did
was shattered the dam the cracks were
forming and then the CEO of Bud Light
just took a sledgehammer to that thing
and the floodgates have erupted and what
happens is for the longest time regular
people are scared if they speak out they
will get canceled they live in fear of
this especially younger people then
people notice that Bud Light is tanking
and they think to themselves whoa
if I say something it's actually popular
now people aren't scared anymore now
they feel good now it feels good to go
shop somewhere else now you post a video
about how you're not going to Target
and what you get a million views yep so
there's even opportunists here we're
going to jump on board this is where I
think the tide shifts because the the
wokeness is falling into
it's falling into the lame cultural
space where it is it is it is becoming
negative it's not it's not interesting
and you know it is kind of what is kind
of interesting is if you look at like
punk rock stuff
these guys were dressing in very very
weird ways that were supposed to be
shocking to the average person you had I
think it was currently my wrong film Sid
Vicious wore the swastika yep yeah the
idea was to offend people to be like I'm
not a part of your thing then all of a
sudden Punk became cool and it became
mainstream and it became multi-billion
dollars how things kind of go
underground has totally disobed like the
actual underground is completely and
totally disappeared in the world of the
internet because part of the underground
used to be you had to physically go to
places to find this music you had to go
to certain record stores you had to go
to certain places to buy certain
magazines you had to go to shows that
were at certain locations it wasn't
presented to you and it wasn't given to
you so you had to put effort into work
for it I worked for you yeah then those
underground things became popular and so
here's what I think for a period you get
this rebellious anti-woke subculture
pushing back on the on the corporations
on Disney on Bud Light Bud Light the
number one brand
like all Trends in counterculture they
start to become more and more dominant
because people who are passionate about
these things believe in them don't give
them up and the average person just
doesn't care so what happens now Bud
Light went from number one to number two
Modelo is now number one and to be
honest Bud Light was always kind of a
number one haha it's very funny I'm very
funny and uh and now it's just crap it
always was but uh this shows that
regular people are are it's this Counter
Culture is now becoming more and more
dominant and moving into the mainstream
space my prediction is in a few years
this we win you know I don't know what
that means politically well I think well
obviously I think on the political
ramifications like if you want to know
how decisions are made in society look
at where the money goes and so if you
can shift The Profit structures of
society back toward the values of
everyday actual normal people uh I think
we win even politically but people ask
me often like do you think Bud Light can
redeem themselves at this point and I
think the clear answer is no because
they've become the butt of a cultural
joke like I saw somebody tweet recently
and it went super viral
um the biggest insult of 2023 is you
look like someone who would drink Bud
Light at Target and I'm like
you're you're now screwed you see all
these funny videos is going around of
people buying a Bud Light and it totally
Alters their personality it's like you
can't come back from that and I think
that what's really exciting about that
is people are waking up to have a
general sort of we talked about this
earlier there's an anti-establishment
sense in society at the moment that I
really Embrace I think it's wonderful
that should also carry into small
businesses so instead of going to Bud
Light why don't you go to a local Brewer
that's making awesome local craft beer
that a lot of this is actually super
affordable they don't hate you they're
not going to lecture you about gender
and it is that simple if you can do that
for all these different Industries like
on Public Square 90 of our businesses
are small businesses and it's great
because those are the ones that are not
going to lecture you about stuff they're
not bought into an ESG agenda or Dei
agenda and they're actually shifting
Society back to like normal people's
values people all the time ask like are
you political and I'm not political I'm
like a normal person from 2006 and it's
just the country somehow you've ended up
here exactly and so when Commerce has
become so politicized and we're just
trying to offer this solution that is
not going to tell you about gender while
you're trying to buy pants for your kids
like it's it's kind of a refreshing
thing for people so you're seeing normal
people wake up and you talked earlier
about how like the social issues of
gender are becoming such a hot button
political topic for the mama bears
seventy percent of American consumers
are moms yeah so if you get that
audience pissed at your brand and ready
for an alternative like that's our
number one demographic on the app it's
70 moms because if you have the mama
bears mobilized to a product they
believe in they're going to tell other
friends they're the best evangelist for
things and alternative is true if they
hate your brand if you become the Target
in their eyes they're gonna thank you
well that's why influencer marketing
initially started with like Mommy
bloggers right they were on the internet
and being like here's my life and people
were like what products you use tell me
everything you do because I am looking
for your recommendation I think that is
an army that uh Bud Light did not think
maybe they should have courted the moms
instead of Doyle Mulvaney they should
have been like well they were trying
they did that commercial with uh that
actor and his wife and it's like the
woman is sitting on the couch and she's
on hold and then that Miles what's his
face the actor grabs two beers and
cracks them up and dances over that was
like couples they didn't like Chase the
moms they weren't like that was
specifically targeting women that was
like report covered in like the ad
marketing news as this is how they'll
get women because typically Bud Light
was like it wasn't effective what I'm
saying is they should have gone harder
in the we're chasing mobs like they
should have been replacing all of the
stairs a wine mom they should have been
like you're a Bud Light mom my point is
they tried that ad it probably didn't
work so they went Don Mulaney yeah
Market to kids I guess bud light off
that's a good conclusion to Market beer
to children but light wasn't exactly or
isn't exactly a great tasting no no it's
number one thing I don't think I think I
think that's a a fallacy but I think
it's important to note that women
control spending in most households
that's not yeah that shouldn't be a
surprise to people I mean that's been
the standard for for as long as I can
remember when I was a kid I heard
stories that women can do most of the
shooting you know do most of the grocery
shopping and and purchasing for the
household because they run the house
they also typically control most of the
philanthropic giving too so any
Charities decided by women so
this is this strange Paradox where uh
women are constantly being told you know
men are oppressing you but really they
have all this power they control
basically American spending and they
don't acknowledge it's been alive for a
long long they don't acknowledge it and
that's that's what bothers that's
because it's not convenient
true I mean like if you're in a position
where like you know everyone's telling
you that you're oppressed and you're
you're you're the the second class
gender and yet you're still bossing your
husband around you're gonna make a whole
lot of noise about no we we don't need
extra benefits from the government blah
blah no you're gonna just shut your
mouth and you're gonna go ahead and say
it's fine let's cut I was gonna jump to
another story if you want to write oh I
actually say Ali Wong has this bit where
she says like feminist ruins everything
by saying by by saying we can do
anything yeah stop talking don't tell
them
we got to jump to this story this is
from uh last night postmanuel says NBC
News defends we're coming for your
children chant at NYC drag March arguing
it's been used for years at Pride events
but it's it's it's more than that they
tweeted the coming for your children
chant has been used for years at Pride
events according to Long Time March
attendees and gay rights activists who
said it's one of the many provocative
Expressions used to regain control role
of slurs against lgbtq people shoes
here's here's the funny thing the new
NBC news article says in the 21 second
clip circulated by a right-wing web
streamer channel is that you that's us
by the way okay that's Tim guest news
former newspaper News Guard certified by
the way it says dozens of people in the
streets can be heard chanting we're here
we're queer we're not going shopping but
one voice that is louder than the crowd
it's not clear whose or whether the
speaker was a member of the lgbtq
community is heard saying at least twice
we're here we're coming for your
children
first of all in the video you can hear
they're all chanting people and you can
see their mouths yeah you can see
multiple people saying this thing no now
here's my point also notice they didn't
why add the clip they're linking it but
they didn't write that in this article
my point is this why are they
simultaneously arguing it's a totally
normal chance they always have done and
also nobody did it it's some it's one
weird person we don't know who that
person is which is it pick one now
here's where here's here's the good part
shoe on head tracked down one of the
sources
pointing out that NBC news said a
leaderless group of activists with the
radical fairies a loose knit lgbtq
Collective and the sisters of Perpetual
Indulgence a charity and protest group
have helped organize the march in more
recent years according post there are no
sponsorships by companies at the drag
March do uh to just clarify NBC News is
reporting a leaderless group of
activists with the radical fairies
helped organize this March where they
chanted were coming for your children
okay
thank you shun head for this one
Henry uh Harry hey uh hey Junior was an
American gay rights activist nambola
activist communist labor Advocate
co-founder of the medicine society as
well as the radical fairies
so it was an outright NAMBLA activist
that what is that North American man boy
love Association the North American man
boy love Association so it was a
communist pedophile who founded this
organization that now goes on to help
organize a March in which they're
chanting we're coming for your children
and NBC news says nothing to see here
folks shout out by the way to elad
eliyahu reporting for timcast news on
the ground who caught this video and I
want to stress this when when ilad
tweeted this video out we didn't think
that much of it was like here they go
again
and then it went crazy viral and it's
gone this far but uh shadowhead for
pulling this information up this is why
you should follow at timcast news on
Twitter because you'd see a lot of stuff
first let's go which by the way the the
headline's so interesting uh it's not
that big of a deal because we've been
doing it for years
make it better that makes it worse that
thing you're scared about we've been
doing it for longer than you realize
they've been writing books about it
since the I mean Eros and Civilization
by Herbert Marquis came out in like the
60s or something like that these are
these Arguments for intergenerational
relationships have been made by queer
theorists for the better part of 50
years this is a a this is a normal
leftist perspective if you're a leftist
like philosophers like skull or whatever
that is normal to hear people will are
going to feel more comfortable as LGBT
issues become more topical people in
Academia are going to feel more
comfortable making the argument that
there is nothing no such thing as
innocence that there is no reason to
prevent children from seeing sexual
activity being sexually active
themselves these are not arguments that
I'm making these are arguments that are
made by people like Michelle Foucault
Herbert Marcus and people that are
cutting edge
in the field of queer Theory and and
Communists yeah they're absolutely
they're all Marxist they're all leftists
they're all they're you know they're
they're all Communists um but when they
organize an event we should think
nothing of it it's fine don't question
this I I I I think different things than
what you're saying so this is like this
article is so weird they're they're Tim
is totally right they're saying we do
this all the time and also it's not a
big deal there's nothing and also that
person's not a part of our group and we
don't even believe it's real this is not
a bad thing this is right now this is a
resource if you look on Twitter the uh
actual tweet that NBC made had a has a
community notes thing on it and stuff so
that is a good thing and it should be
used by everybody that wants to fight
the left and the the literal attack on
children because what we're talking
about is their admission that they want
to Target children the specific reason
is because they want to interrupt the
way that adults raise their children
because grown-ups raise children that
are well adjusted and happy are not
revolutionary they don't end up in queer
Lifestyles generally they they just
don't end up in in you know doing a lot
of drugs and out on the street and the
left wants people in those conditions
because unhappy people are
revolutionaries happy satisfied people
are not revolutionaries and the left is
full of actual communist revolutionaries
so your kids are their target and that
is not an exaggeration they want to
raise your kids to be revolutionaries
they want to raise your kids to hate you
that is a true statement
sorry don't let your kids be on Tick
Tock no for real like the V vac Rama
Swami right now saying kids under 16
should not be allowed on any of these
social apps like I think it's one of the
best political positions I've heard in a
long time because if you I'm fully
convinced if kids did not have Tick Tock
at 14 and did not I don't know what
you're allowed to say on YouTube but
corn they didn't have corn or they
didn't uh watch Tick Tock like I'm
convinced the trans thing wouldn't even
exist it's this weird fetish culture
paired with these Tick-Tock algorithms
that are just prolonging it and that is
why we have well you you have you have
children I want people who have kids to
imagine this right I I just I mean I
shouldn't even say that anybody just
imagine this
you have a 12 year old
they go outside and they're walking
around by themselves and let's say
they're riding their bike they ride
their bike a few miles and they come
across an old Warehouse
to sex club they go inside by themselves
and there's a bunch of people engaged in
lewd and lascivious behaviors and they
all start talking to the kid and
inviting the kid over to partake that's
the internet the internet with your kids
on the Internet is you being like have
fun good luck and your kids could
stumble across
these sex clubs and they're going to see
these things and watch it and have
groomers groom them and we've heard this
for many uh individuals in fact what
you're referring to
we actually had a couple of d
transitioners
explain to us that they're going on in
places like Tumblr
and they'll get people saying like hey
why don't you try wearing some boys
clothes and see how you feel post some
pictures they do what happens next they
get bombarded by likes and comments
about how cool they are they feel good
then they say did you feel good when you
didn't like yeah it felt really good and
like do more
what actually feels good is the social
acceptance yeah belonging belonging yeah
and then they keep telling these kids to
do more and more and more and more and
that was the story we heard explicitly
from one detransitioned individual so
all that really matters
don't let your kids go to adult events
don't let your kids be exposed to us but
I agree with you if it makes position on
this stuff I we were talking about this
last night
if you go out in public and you hold up
a big sign a big picture of porn
you're gonna get arrested or at the very
least accounts are gonna take it from
you they're gonna cite you or arrest you
or it's like obscenity laws
if you speak your political mind you're
fine
if you go online and speak your
political mind you will be destroyed but
of course porn is everywhere and totally
acceptable on the internet so it's
backwards the internet is is is a is a
lawless Wild West place and a lot of
people are saying it's losing its Wild
West Edge and there were good things
about it when it was the Wild West in
fact in the in that you could have a
decentralized network of your friends
actually doing productive things but
what happened was the internet started
with a bunch of tech nerds
and that's why you end up with in the
early days cool things happening online
cool stories then people who want to
hide from the mainstream start using it
and you get weirdos using the internet
and weird things on the internet
now you have the mainstreaming and the
centralization of the internet where
everything's becoming more like apps
it's it's less free less free-flowing
less less about the domain and more
about the app you're using
but still we've not codified anything to
say keep kids out of these adult
facilities these on the internet that
needs to happen yep yeah I don't think
think there's a benefit to it I was
thinking about recently
um I wrote this story about how Middle
School test scores are sort of tanking
and this we saw a huge drop in the
National report card in 2012. and for me
it's impossible I know I can't prove
correlation or causation but uh Snapchat
got released in July of 2011 and uh
Instagram got released in October of
2010 and I think
it's interesting because a specific
study talked about how fewer kids choose
to read for fun uh on their own and
that's true of all performance levels
and now you wonder what are they doing
are they outside running around more are
they what no they're all on Tick Tock
they're on Instagram they're on Snapchat
they're completely devoted to the screen
and it's they're suffering because of it
again there are probably lots of things
that factor into this but I don't think
we can deny that social media has
changed childhood or at least
preteenthood forever and I don't know
that it's beneficial people who say oh
you have to connect with people and find
your community like shouldn't we be
encouraging kids to do this in person to
have in-person conversations and to find
communities that they see face to face
that we know are not someone else there
was a reason that show Catfish got so
popular right because it reminds you
constantly that you don't know exactly
who you're talking to on the internet
unless you have actually met them and if
it can happen to you when you're you
know 21 and talking to someone online
think of what can happen to basically an
even more gullible child who gets online
at 12. yeah well and it's so widespread
and sadly like
most of society does not live on Twitter
and see these videos go viral we have
340 million people in our country the
vast majority of them will never see
that video of that chant so what's
concerning is you'll tell them they're
trying to groom your kids look they're
admitting it but they don't see that
like most average moms and dads still
believe that the public schools are
wonderful our teachers would never groom
the kids they're not actually they just
want a quality like they're again a lot
of people stuck in this they don't
realize it's changing I hope so but but
Bud Light proves it that's that's prove
it that's true once it becomes that
mainstream my problem is is that there's
still too much of a denial that our
country has related to things like this
do you remember two years ago when the
San Francisco gay choir during Zoom came
out and literally saying we're coming
for your children it's like they've been
telling us for years what they're trying
to do why are we just now waking up to
it I think part of the reason why why
we're just now waking up to it is is
because people have not had a lot
there's not been a lot of voices
articulating
what the actual intent is like the fact
that the that there is a a an effort
made by people on the left to interrupt
the raising of children so that way they
can change their opinions to be a
socialist opinion that's looked at as a
conspiracy theory right
I I think that's only one small element
of it I I think the bigger picture is
just that
the Occam's razor suggest they're people
who are want to abuse kids well no there
are what I'm saying is I'm saying that
the the the the fact that the that
people can articulate that that there is
a process that happens like when you
raise your kids you create more liberals
essentially it's what happens in America
liberals have liberal values raise your
kids to be liberal what the what a
socialist wants to do is interrupt that
raise that insta instilling kids with
liberal values they want to stop that
prevent parents from instilling Liberal
values in their church I mean like
classical liberal Yeah well yeah well
you know things like freedom of speech
yeah the idea that of freedom of speech
is no longer something that gen gen Z
looks as really really valuable and
there are people that make the argument
that the freedom of speech might not be
a good thing and the the reason that
they make that argument is because there
are people that are teaching them well
instead of saying look it's super
important because if you don't have free
speech X Y and Z happen we well you have
people that come in and say well you
know X Y and Z might happen but you also
need to be worried about a b and c
because if you say bad things it'll hurt
people Etc and and the the importance of
liberal values is not being instilled in
in the younger generation and without
the younger generation being instilled
with liberal values
they're not going to be they're not
going to look at at our society as as
this you know the same way that their
parents did and so the left is looking
to interrupt that that creation or
Recreation of society and they're
looking to to interject their own values
into more kids and I think that that are
the fact that parents have heard that
somewhat and may have been aware of it
you see that when when there are people
saying we're coming for your children
that is a tangible reality that you can
associate with a story that you told
them right I'm I'm telling you look the
left is coming for your kids and they're
like can this is why and they want to
teach your kids and parents be like that
guy's crazy whatever they could blow it
off you show them that and they're like
whoa
do you think we should change how we
phrase it then like instead of being
like the left's coming for your kids
should we say like hey you have to be
careful about the content that your
children are consuming I think people
get turned off by politics and so they
start saying like oh you're just being
too political but if you were to say hey
I don't think you want your kid exposed
to sexual material you probably
shouldn't take them to this event or you
should be wary about this thing it
becomes more palatable personally that's
why vivex trying to make it policy is
because most people don't respond to the
hyper social uh like culture War
language they'd respond more to like
here are the dangers of social media and
the government's role is to protect you
from danger that's not the the way he's
trying to frame it I think social media
for at least for me personally I think
the effect that the the
government's involvement in social media
should be very delicate I'm not super
I'm very against the government you know
censoring or whatever I do think that
the government should be extremely aware
of what curriculum is being taught to
children and that's not just something
that that is in public schools either
because there are companies that are
private companies that produce the
curriculum that gets put in schools and
if those companies are producing
corrupted materials they're producing
books that have these these ideologies
written into them things that are
influenced by people like people like
Paulo Ferrari and stuff if that's the
curriculum being sold to private schools
as well as public schools going to
private schools is no longer a good
enough thing because they're still being
taught the same curriculum so it has to
be you have to make sure that the
ideology that is the ideology is not
injected into the curriculum and that
takes parents being aware of what the
ideology is they have to be able to
identify gender of issues and it's not
it's not a small in any way it's not a
small ask like this is a big long-term
project that people need to undertake if
they're going to save the United States
from a legit limit cultural revolution
because I I agree on a lot of that the
the social media part I have a tough
time with because like Twitter says that
13 and up is allowed to use it and
Twitter also has pornography and you've
been on Twitter before where it's people
reply to popular posts with like
sexually explicit content that kids are
then now able to see 14 year olds that
could be illegal it should be illegal
absolutely you either up to age or you
make porn on Twitter illegal I I think
that you should probably do both but
um back to an earlier point you made do
you think though that parents reverting
to Liberal values will help things
because isn't liberalism essentially
Live and Let Live it's that this is the
way they choose to live and you gotta
respect everybody chooses to live
because I actually see it a little
different I think that the only people
that have been right consistently for
the past 10 years were the religious
conservatives that were like it's a
slippery slope it's a slippery slope
they're coming for your kids and they
were laughed off as fundamentalists that
were too uh
um too Prissy
Thumpers when in reality they were right
like my grandma who warned us all that
this is a slippery slope and if you let
them get away with the stuff they're
gonna teach your kids and adoption kids
like that wasn't seen as a liberal value
I don't see it as a slippery slope I see
it as
hey here's the thing that we've we now
think is acceptable here's the thing we
we see as unacceptable so you just see
the Overton window shifting it's like
well I mean
I don't care if some dude and a woman go
into the privacy of their own home and
like swing around ceiling fans and do
backflips on weird bondage frames I care
when they film it and then start showing
little kids
that it's not a slippery slope these
people have always existed have always
tried to do these things the slippery
slope if there is one is the internet
and it's not that we say allowed gay
marriage
but if anything culture has become more
accepting of more radical and extreme
things it's the internet
if the idea was Live and Let Live means
whatever you do in the privacy of your
home own home that works in the privacy
of your own home the problem now is some
person will post
obscene images on the internet and
expose kids to it and we don't do
anything about that that should be
illegal it it's kind of crazy to me that
we are in a day and age come on and
anybody knows if you go to a playground
and you post obscene material you're
gonna get arrested but if you go to
Pride they don't care there's a there's
a clear double standard on the internet
I have questions this is what I proposed
to YouTube there is a there's a video
out of Santa I think it was a um West
Hollywood where two men are on a truck
performing a foreplay sex act on each
other in in public in front of everybody
children were present so I said okay
YouTube
let's see how you tolerate this will
YouTube allow this video I need to check
to see if it was demonetized but it
wasn't banned or anything like that
the issue is this
you cannot do you you
ten years ago we talked about a slippery
slope yeah in the privacy of your own
home you could two guys two women
whatever three guys two women two guys
whatever
they weren't doing it in public so
nobody was concerned about it the
internet is public they're now doing it
in public that's the problem and if
there is a problem needs to be fixed
it's you should not be allowed to
publish these things in public
there you go problem solved I think it's
a both hand I think yes it's the
internet that's that's basically numb
dark culture to a bunch of awful content
that should be seen as egregious and
people absolutely revolt against but at
the same time I also believe like in
California we've got state senator
Anthony Weiner who's coming up with some
new crazy radical proposal related to
sex every single day and that's not
internet related that's purely policy
it's talking about what forms of abuse
they can get away with to kids and it's
consistently passing the legislature
like it's making it through these
committees because ten years ago we
would have said well it may be because
of the internet but the fact is people
in their I do think there's a level of
this like well I said Live and Let Live
ten years ago I still believe that I
have this sort of framework of people do
what they want and I who am I to judge
that's a very liberal principle whereas
someone who's more conservative like me
would say I actually think there's an
objective line that we should all agree
to if this wasn't on the internet people
would not fear the negative press so
these politicians are like if I oppose
this people will attack me online it's
it's the internet
so it's many of these politicians are
just going to say what I think is
popular
well the video from Pride got a million
clicks that's what they're going to
agree with so it I I really just think
when it comes to liberals there's no
moral framework there's literally not
they're just they'll lie about
everything they I mean look at this we
we had the person on the show and I'll
keep it somewhat vague because I'm tired
of talking about it who I said they they
like this we have this book right here
yeah this book is gay that describes
things children should not be hearing
yeah and they they said it shouldn't be
censored from schools advocacy for a
book
that is not for children being given to
children that would teach children how
to use adult sex apps they agree with it
why because the internet said too
there's if there was no internet they
would just say whatever the TV told them
to say so I guess my question is what
ideology stops that from happening
because I would argue that it's not
Classical liberalism anymore I think my
opinion is that there is the need for a
conservative Uprising against this of
family values LED
policies ideologies uh cultural
statements companies that say like no no
we're gonna go back to the basics here
stop talking about any of this no matter
if you're an adult or a kid we don't
want to hear about your sex life at all
anymore the founding fathers were
classical liberals
yeah I think they would roll in their
grave at the social stuff we've allowed
in our Classical liberalism though so
but but it's not Classical liberalism
it's it's corruption and degradation and
degeneracy but you just said liberals
don't have a moral framework so where
does so when I say liberal I'm talking
about culture like yeah colloquially we
use liberal to refer to a body of people
but it doesn't actually describe
liberalism yeah Thomas Jefferson a
classical liberal would as you're
correct Roland is he's spin so fast in
this grave who generate free energy yes
so Tesla exactly just yeah you know we
could we could hook up some cables those
coffins and we'll be powering this
country for forever yeah so Classical
liberalism is more about individuality
meritocracy Etc and even conservatives
agree with the principles of the
founding fathers in that regard the
seeds that were planted in this country
that granted people civil rights
someone going outside and plotting and
declaring they're going to come and
commit crimes against your children
those are criminal acts the cops aren't
arresting these people it is not
Classical liberalism that we have laws
being broken every day that police won't
arrest people for it's it's just general
social Decay yeah so I guess I come back
to like our constitutions only Built for
immoral and virtuous people even amongst
the classical liberals they had such a
sense of conserving something pure that
we all have to agree on that or else the
society is going to fall apart so I
guess my thing is like if if we wanted
to redeem so much of the cultural
degradation that's taking place like do
you is the goal just to bring it back to
a state where everyone's just sort of
Live and Let Live except for when it
affects the kids what's the goal because
I see most of my classical liberal
friends sort of not being on the front
lines of a lot of this and not really
Karen where it's my conservative friends
that are the ones leading the charge
it's the mama bears that are
conservative leading the charging are
you talking about classical liberals or
traditional liberals I'm talking about
classical liberals that would not in
terms of leftist I'm making a
distinction between leftist and liberal
I'm hearing you say that parents lost
the teaching of liberal values to their
children and that's what led to a lot of
culturals and societal Decay and I would
argue that it's actually parents
becoming too liberal that has led to a
lot of this Decay and that there's a
need for more conserving and
conservatism back in society and in the
household because we've allowed the the
line of acceptability to just completely
leave sight it's it's past the Horizon
at this point the way that I understand
or the way that I use liberal and stuff
like that I to me conservatives are
conserving liberal values right
progressives are trying to progress
Beyond liberal values
um and I'm I think more about the
philosophy behind the left and the right
so someone like Rousseau would be like
the kind of the father of modern leftism
and where and whereas like Adam Smith
and would be you know the founders of
this country would kind of be the
liberal idea that or what I think of as
a liberal so I I don't think that we
need to have strict controls on people's
private lives I don't think that that we
need to worry about who's having sex
with who I do like I'm I'm the guy that
wants to get rid of the whole department
of education just get rid of it I'm with
you so like I'm a very small government
guy I want to get rid of as much
bureaucracy as possible and I think that
a combination of getting rid of the
bureaucracy behind the education of
children is I think that's a it's a
start but it's not going to fix
everything because like I said this
stuff is in the curriculum as well so
there has to be people that are looking
that are teaching liberalism as in the
fundamental rights of individual liberty
and stuff like that and that even goes
to the idea that your word is important
so like progressives the philosophy on
the left doesn't come from the
philosophy of that we can actually
interact with reality right they believe
that perspective matters and lived
experience matters Etc and these are
broad ideas that I'm talking about so
there's going to be people that are
going to disagree with me but for for
purposes of this argument people on the
left don't think things like your word
or being honest are important because
they're consequentialists and they're
post-modernists and so they don't
believe that truth is a thing that you
can actually come in contact with they
believe that the consequences matter so
they'll lie to you so we need to have a
we need to have people explain why
things like consequentialism are bad and
you don't do it by telling a child that
consequentialism is bad you tell them
look it's important to tell the truth
and here's why that's something people
can understand I think uh one of the big
issues is conservatives for a long time
blindly just supported cops yeah and so
you have
um
you have right now one of the issues in
West Virginia is they did a drag show
with kids and so the people in the
community are like hey are they going to
arrest these people well we've seen
nothing so far it's only been a couple
of weeks we'll see but no one really
thinks the the AG was going to go after
them despite the fact it's illegal and
it is illegal because here's the funny
thing and I got I pulled them all up
again
it's so illegal in West Virginia it is
illegal to engage uh to cohabitate with
someone
seriously look uh no person's not
married to each other shall lutely or
listen and lasciviously Associate and
cohabitate together or whether Merit or
not be guilty of open or gross lewdness
and lasciviousness that's still a law an
act of law one of six states that still
has a law in the book says if you are
not mayor you can't live together wow
I'm not suggesting they actually enforce
a law like that yeah my point is if that
law still in the books you better damn
well believe a man wearing skimpy
women's clothing and engaging in a sex
show in public with children on stage is
illegal yes why won't they just enforce
the existing laws now hey if the left
thinks the laws are bad they can go to
legislature and change those laws but in
West Virginia the the this Democratic
institution is spoken and it is illegal
to do these things in fact Jefferson
County explicitly recently passed a
Norton saying you can't do these things
the problem is as people in big cities
started engaging and pushing the
boundary more and more and more cops
were not enforcing the law
and so conservatives just kept saying
keep doing your your gr your good old
job and now we're at the point where I
guess they're called what blue laws
where it's like they're laws but no one
would seriously enforce it so you'll end
up now with an adult having a sex
performance I mean look at that kid
that little kid dancing at an adult gay
club taking his clothes off on stage in
exchange for tips and this was like four
or five years ago it's disgusting and no
police action you had the the drag show
with kids in Texas and the cops were
like we can't do anything about it and a
bunch of people pointing out like yo
it's there's a law right here saying you
can't absolutely can do something about
it but the cops are like no and
conservatives just kept saying back the
blue no I'm like just I think
we should just abolish the police
just just look go back to militias go
back to the law enforcement is in the
hands of the community exactly what the
left wanted right but let's entertain
this I'm not talking about social
workers showing up and going everyone
calm down I'm talking about if you come
onto a public if you come onto a
residential street it is the
neighborhood watch who is empowered to
enforce the laws in in their residences
that means when antifa shows up with
bricks it is the local the local
neighborhood watch who comes out detains
the individuals and then has them
arrested instead what happens is the
cops show up and they say you know look
if we arrest these guys it'll make a
bigger ride so we're gonna let them
Rampage through your neighborhood now
enforce the communities how about that
give the left exactly what they're
asking for because if the cops aren't
going to arrest the people breaking the
law why should I care if we have cops
look
we've got Mass riding are there are is
are the is the federal law enforcement
arresting antifa no they're arresting
Trump supporters they're arresting
pro-lifers I am not going to sit here
and defend police when it's when law
enforcement is going to some some
pro-liferous house because they stood in
front of a Planned Parenthood I don't
okay fine you want to make that illegal
they they went in front of the homes of
the Supreme Court Justice is also legal
and those people didn't get arrested so
they closed all right businesses during
covid so they don't shut down a drag
March but they do shut down the church
that stayed open in Kentucky during
covid absurd I'm saying look trust me I
I agree I think that uh I have more hope
for local police departments than I do
for the FBI for example because it's so
centralized and bureaucratic and corrupt
at this point you can't redeem it so
just get rid of it local police
departments it was interesting during
Coven in California because if you were
if you were with Riverside
you were a cop that respected the rule
of law you were not going to shut down
businesses you had a sheriff in the
county that was very much on the side of
individual liberties and you had a
really respecting police force that
actually did their job really well if
you're in La though you were shutting
off people's power who were hosting
House parties during covid and it was by
those cops that did the same thing so
trust me they're blindly back the blue
there was I'm not saying you are but
there's no 100 it is there was a woman
in Minnesota who opened her Cafe
they file the charges against her she
fled and the sheriff haunted her down
and arrested her and uh so look
you you you see this across the board
right in New Jersey in Suburban Southern
New Jersey cops went and shot attila's
gym down these cops don't care no they
don't they don't enforce the law they
will stand like
Luke gradkowski filmed uh an interview
with a guy who's on a train a Madman
with a knife started stabbing people and
the cops were like we're not going to do
anything about that the cops in New York
City are going to give you a ticket but
they can't stop crime they're not gonna
be wrong there are good cops we have a
video going far right now of a cop
talking to kids about seat belts then he
hears gunshots he runs straight into
danger hero you got the the cops who ran
to that school when that that trans Mass
shooter was shooting and they did it by
the book and they they stopped that
threat and they saved lives Heroes there
are a ton of good cops the issue though
is
police have are no longer members of the
community in regard to what we think is
acceptable they don't want to be
involved so when in Texas you have angry
people from this area being like these
people don't live here and they're
putting bringing children to a sex show
the cops go well I'm not going to get
involved
all it takes is for One Cop to be like
I'll arrest them yeah it's illegal nope
they don't do it they're afraid they're
gonna lose their job and Society has
given them every reason to be afraid
they're going to lose their job it's why
they uh it's why culture celebrates uh
the victim or excuse me they celebrate
the perpetrator of the crime instead of
the guy who jumps in and stops at Jacob
Penny or whatever in New York recently
Daniel yesterday I pleaded not guilty
well good he was not guilty of anything
it was a perfectly legitimate scenario
where the women and the children on the
subway were literally saying thank you
to this guy so why are we not taking a
lesson from him that's what I really
agree with your point that like it
should be communities that are respected
cops arrested him yeah it's absurd and
that right there was the best case story
I think for what you're describing which
is how on Earth was the the the guy who
uh was terrorizing women and children on
the subway seen as some sort of hero
because he used to dance on the on the
subway platform while the guy who's
actually stepping in to protect women
and children's one getting arrested
liberal values would have said that you
protect people like that's what that
would be the liberal thing to do protect
the individuals yeah it's just sad how
those terms have become so distorted
because Daniel Penny was initially
questioned by police and released and
then later Alvin Bragg was like just
kidding we need to arrest that guy so
you mean to tell me that Alvin Bragg in
New York will arrest a guy even though
the police are already determined itself
defense but Morrissey in West Virginia
won't arrest the people putting on sex
shows in public with children that is
the problem yep so you know I've met
I've met Morrissey and I'm getting more
and more uh upset one of the issues is
that we're trying to open businesses in
West Virginia but if it is the case that
West Virginia is a state that allows
adults to have sex shows in public with
children present as they did in
Martinsburg this past week and we and we
got video of it and the AG won't do
anything about it then I suggest
divesting from West Virginia because
screw that Texas and and Florida are
doing a lot better on these fronts and
everybody kept screaming go to Florida
instead I gotta be honest I just I like
the mountains I like the people here
it's Maga country it's 86 Trump
supporting most people are in agreement
so I'm not trying to come down hard on
the AG right now because I don't know
what he's doing but I expect to see
action taken in this regard Jefferson
County banned this stuff that the people
who live here are pissed off about it
and the people who are coming and
bringing the stuff here don't live here
so I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I am frustrated
that you get an AG in New York you get
an AG in in my uh in DC in uh you get
two ages you get the I'll get Alvin
Bragg well on both ends it's going after
Trump yeah going after Penny clearly
ideological prosecutions when we
actually have a law on the books we see
nothing this is the problem you want to
fix you want to fix all of this it's
really simple
red States need to actually just enforce
the law and stop being whiny little cry
babies who are like but the New York
Times will insult me and I'm up for
re-election
fine I ain't voting for you but we'll
see maybe Morsi will do the right thing
and it'll actually start bringing
charges against the people who organize
this event because we've got video
footage of it and I'm supposed to I'm
supposed to start a business in this
multiple I'm supposed to move my
business here I'm supposed to set up a
public in uh or a brick and mortar shop
and you mean to tell me that nearby
they're putting on sex shows and they're
bringing kids to them I expect the AG to
actually bring charges to people who
organized and put on this event as the
law states you cannot do look I can
simplify it for you this law says if two
people whether married or not engage in
open gross lewdness it's a misdemeanor
that's every Pride March well I look
call it whatever you want I'm telling
you if if we've got video of people
putting on adults sex shows and bringing
kids involved that is more than just
open lewdness where is the AG to
immediately come now you know what
they're scared they're terrified they're
scared they're scared of all of these
people well if you're if you're in West
Virginia and you're law enforcement and
you are letting this stuff happen I
assure you the people who live in West
Virginia are very very angry very very
angry look the joke is up on the
mountain it's a bunch of right-wing nut
jobs Jefferson County explicitly banned
children being at drag performances
where are the cops granted granted what
I'm talking about outside of that is
Berkeley County my point is the
residents of this area the opinion
doesn't just shift when you cross county
lines no the people in Berkeley County
are pissed off about this I talk to them
I'm pissed off about it because I'm
spending money here mostly let me
clarify I'm not saying that uh uh we we
will see what the AG does what the
sheriff's department does or the local
police do if anything
I'll give him time I'm just pissed off
that we can see in California in New
York in Illinois they release all of
these criminals they arrest the victims
and then where we live when we expect a
rule of law we still don't get it when
if you can't have it happen in West
Virginia this is supposed to be like the
safest Haven for people that believe
that this type of nonsense is disgusting
and grotesque like 86 Maga country you
would think that the D.A here of all
places would say yeah you know what I
can go arrest and know that I'm going to
have a win in the court of public
opinion that the public will back me my
constituents will re-elect me because
they see me taking a stance Against
Child indoctrination if that can't
happen here something's deeply flawed
because this should be the place well I
don't want to jump the gun just yet
because this was just like two weeks ago
right so there and and there are people
telling me that they're reaching out to
the office and they're demanding action
in this regard maybe we'll see something
I hope you do maybe we need to organize
some protests maybe we need to take a
page out of the uh valinsky's book and
start utilizing their own tactics
against them maybe we need to bring
people out for a peaceful March through
these streets demanding an end of this
not letting it happen again yep
let's go to super chats if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the share with your friends become a
member at dimcast.com we're gonna have a
members only uncensored show coming up
for you in about a half an hour we'll be
at 10 p.m at timcast.com on the front
page you don't want to miss it but uh
let's read what you all have to say
all right I'm not your buddy guy says I
don't know or have any relation to
Annette Lewis but she's the albertan
woman I mentioned last week who has
denied an organ transplant for not being
coveted vaxxed if we can help her with
prayer as an aid that would be amazing
sorry to hear that's horrifying uh hope
for hope for the best
Leif Hagin says to sandus just said on
Fox that he supports eliminating the
Departments of Education Commerce energy
and the IRS
wow that's fantastic I look forward to
him deleting that war room tweet where
he put up deep fakes and then we'll
consider voting for him how about that
yep
yeah I'm not I I like all the things
he's saying but actions speak louder
than words if if DeSantis is saying he's
going to do all these really great
things
I mean he's got to prove he actually
cares about doing the right thing and
take down one tweet this is the funny
thing it's from the fourth I think it's
been a month and they can't just delete
it and be like we shouldn't put that up
I I do not believe they are sincere and
being genuine when they when he says he
wants to do these things
sorry but y'all can do whatever you want
I'm not saying you don't have to vote
for him you got to look at who funds
them
to me it all comes down to the funding
who's backing it with money and uh I
don't don't love the community of fun
that's true that I I I'm not as big on
that you know they they ragged on Rubio
for getting NRA money and he was like
they're not giving me money to do things
they're giving money because of the
things I do and that's the point
I don't care who's giving to Santa's
money but understand the people who are
giving them money are giving him money
because he's doing something they like
yeah I expect him to do yeah I I I love
that too I I get concerned that
sometimes though with some politicians
especially ones that have been known to
sort of go where the political winds
blow I.E sort of Jeb Bush in 2016 that
the funding really does matter and
there's a reason why Trump was the most
Grassroots funding campaign that the
country's ever seen because he spoken
language of the people so he wasn't
beholden to anybody at least removes a
Temptation when you're funded by the
people because you're not having to
answer to anybody else that may remove
their campaign funding if you're not
operating in a way that they like
all right Dark Gift says super
coincidence just heard of Public Square
last week and loved the app so much just
got my business listed as of yesterday
hey thank you thanks for joining us
that's awesome what's your business
Shout It Out we'd love to promote you
right on both Siva says do you think New
Hampshire will remain a free state or
will its blue neighbor slowly forced to
become a Kami woke state will freedom
win you know Lou gradkowski was like you
got to go to New Hampshire you got to go
to New Hampshire nice and Florida yeah
but I said dude the issue with New
Hampshire is you're surrounded by Blue
States yeah so I mean it may be a nice
little Safe Haven so long as this system
is existing but in the event of social
breakdown you're surrounded the worst
thing about Florida is January I'm sorry
worst thing about New Hampshire is
January yeah New England you mean
there's snow oh God it can be awful up
there yes nah I think that'd be awesome
New England as long as you've got a good
strong internet connection and you know
hunker down you prepare you go
snowboarding we're returning to the
internet connection uh broadband no I
mean New England good because you do
have people who vote right but there's
just not enough of them to turn the
state so like Maine is very famously you
know they send Angus King up every year
and it's it is a purple state but they
will ultimately always end up blue at
least right now I'd love to see a shift
it's probably not going to happen we
just moved our headquarters to Florida
this month right on June moved from San
Diego we're political refugees to uh
yeah Palm Beach Florida I can't do this
now I do I have a lot of well I like
this now West Virginia didn't have any
this year which kind of sucked but um
this area had snow no no snow this year
wow it's like the first time in a long
time yeah and the and the fruit is all
massive like so we have pawpaw which is
they call hillbilly banana and normally
you'll notice little buds growing this
time of year and then in October they're
massive they're already massive so I'm
wondering if the warm weather has caused
them to grow earlier the the fruit
season happened a lot earlier but uh
it's crazy we got grapes everywhere wow
I'm wondering if that may be because it
was so warm that uh the year before when
it's no you know several times uh and
you get grapes out here they're called
Frost grapes when when at first Frost
they become sweet it goes from like tart
to sweet now they're everywhere and and
we think it may be that because it was
so warm the plants got an early start in
spreading and growing and stuff what's
the hillbilly banana called Paul Paul
does it look like a banana no that it
looks more like
um I don't know potato yeah I'd say
potato what's it taste it's supposed to
be like the texture it tastes like if
you took mango banana and avocado and
mashed it all together
avocado is interesting yeah maybe mango
banana mix is probably a better way to
describe it gotcha but it's kind of
sweet oh it's definitely sweet yeah it's
a it's a it's a it's like a it's a you
peel it open and it's got a it's like
mango inside people make it like into
all kinds of things but first time one
of the first times I had it it was as
soda uh and it you could you could sell
it alongside you know Citrus sodas or
pineapple or whatever it's really nice
the fruits that we typically have in
stores are because they're easy to grow
in transport so we have probably five
billion mulberries and the people I I
can't eat them I'm allergic but
everybody loves them and they pick them
up if you just eat them and uh you can't
transform them they break too easily
then we've got wild black raspberry you
can't buy them in stores for the most
part because the yield is too low so
it's not a cash crop but you've got
little black raspberries everywhere you
can pick them and just eat them nobody
wants to invest in growing a low-yield
crop then we have wine berries
everywhere they're wine raspberries
they're Chinese raspberries
there's probably 50 billion of them
they're literally everywhere you just
grab a handful they're like it's amazing
they're like little candies this is
amazing
all right T-Rex Pet Shop says we're so
grateful for Public Square T-Rex Pet
Shop has grown significantly as a result
of Public Square if you don't like woke
pet stores like PetSmart chewy and Petco
support us as an anti-welk alternative
Michael do you have pets I do not have a
pet I'm allergic to pretty much
everything but T-Rex Pet Shop you guys
are awesome I was actually introduced to
your stuff last week so a big fan of
T-Rex Pet Shop awesome why are we
introduce our stuff if you're allergic
to everything well because our Instagram
Community loved them oh yeah so everyone
was messaging about t-rex Pet Shop
there's uh there's some really cool prep
Pet Brands on the app and they were the
one that kept getting shouted out last
week in a certain post we do these
shopping guides where we say ditch chewy
and replace it with these companies that
are on the app and they were one of them
so shout out to T-Rex Pet Shop that's
pretty cool yeah we we have a uh Mr
Bocas has to get a very special food
it's like prescription food so I don't
know I don't T-Rex I don't know if you
mentioned if you had that we were
talking about it before but we're going
to like specialty shops like online to
find it maybe T-Rex you got them hook
them up what do we got here Eric Miller
says question for Michael how about
having a media tab for Public Square you
could advertise movies like the sound of
Freedom Comics like ripperverse and
music like trash House Records
it's an amazing question uh I will say
this our philosophy as a company is to
nail it before we scale it and so we
have a massive amount in front of us
which is Commerce we are trying to
literally become the Amazon replacement
uh and we're trying to do it in half the
time it took them and so we have a
massive uh set of challenges ahead of us
which we are going to excel at and
exceed all expectations on but uh we
will focus on that mountain first and
then we will worry about others having a
media alternative though is an amazing
idea and I would love to one day
incorporate it there's actually an
incredible company called Lore you
familiar with lore dot TV they're
amazing check out Lord yeah it's really
cool you basically they're they're
basically us for films and they actually
allow for consumers to help fund the
films they want to see create pretty
cool so shout out to Laura but I love
the recommendation we certainly want
more freedom media and Liberty focused
media that's for sure Jack Domingo
Conway says I had a work social in San
Diego last week I was able to push the
conversation to Mike Hess Brewing I
didn't tell anyone it was a Public
Square business
here's what you do
right now all of you download Public
Square
go on to the app look for companies that
your company your business uses and
switch to those businesses so imagine
you go to your you go to your uh maybe
maybe you have an office and you go in
the break room and there's coffee and
there's snacks what do you do you
replace all the coffee with Casper
coffee you go to you anything you need
that you normally have to buy from one
of the big chains go to Public Square
first and see if you can find something
from a company that doesn't hate you
even you know what and I'll even say
this
even if a company
just doesn't care one way or the other
about you you're still better off going
to Public Square because those companies
agree with you on American values this
is what it's all about a lot of the
stuff that people need to understand
when it comes to purchases are like
business scale stuff
so you know we were talking about
anheuser-busch's stock going down
how much of that is retail investors
very little it's big institutions that
are buying stock and the reason it only
goes moves in certain directions a
little bit is because a big investment
firm isn't going to sell off every
single share retail investors probably
sold but they make up a small portion
think about this there's a imagine
there's like a guy who's got an office
building with like 10 floors and there's
10 break rooms so they're spending five
thousand dollars a month on coffee for
their couple hundred employees imagine
if you went to Public Square found a
coffee company that was competitive and
liked you
and switched to that coffee instead or
to those notepads or to those pens or
whatever it is you might want now you're
taking funding away from the massive
multinational corporation and giving it
to people who actually care about your
values that's what's got to happen it's
amazing that's the plan
yeah so it could be anything but this is
what uh Jack Domingo's mentioning a work
social okay the next time your company
is like Hey we're doing a picnic a big
thing for the family you know why don't
you uh order stuff say okay go to Public
Square and try and get everything you
can from those from those businesses
some local some order online whatever
whatever it is you can do they say Mike
caspering was that yeah the guy's a
legend he's a patriot and a San Diego
business that's really well known for
super high quality stuff and actually
that's an important note we were talking
about Bud Light earlier how it's
basically liquid piss
um like if if a company like that was
able to get so successful and their
product sucks like I I what I love about
your coffee company and the companies
that have been already mentioned that
are on Public Square is like the only
way we win is ultimately if the products
are really high quality also because if
we're promoting Alternatives that are
garbage we're not going to win in the
long run people will go find the quality
but what if you knew that there are
actually tens of thousands of businesses
that like you they don't hate you they
don't want to indoctrinate you or your
kids and they happen to offer really
high quality stuff so shout out so this
is our Appalachian nights let's go we we
got a bunch of samples sent to us from
from a distributor from a roaster and
then we we made our own blend and then
tried it and it was really good then had
them perfectly formulate it and I think
it's it's the best coffee I've ever had
I mean can I read your mission on the
back this is so cool born of a desire
for a bold coffee and a need to build
companies that support American Values
cast brew coffee was built to provide an
alternative to the faceless corporate
ecosystem and to foster a parallel
economy that supports freedom that's
amazing yeah you tapped into a desire
too like we've talked a lot about the
right left conservative Progressive all
that but there's a much deeper desire
that goes way past political lines which
is there are a few corporations that run
everything and they don't like us and
regardless of political affiliation
nobody likes shopping with Amazon
because it's a bunch of nameless
faceless corporate brands that don't
actually have a story to tell whereas
there are thousands of small businesses
like this that actually contribute
something positive to society more than
just a good profit margin which I
appreciate so Starbucks views you and me
like bees producing honey
if a bee dies they don't think twice
they walk up they wear their protective
gear because they're worried about
potential backlash they go and they
harvest the honey as we swarm around and
they don't care what we're saying or
what we're doing they just want to make
sure they're not going to anger The Hive
and cause problems while they get the
honey out
I don't like that I want to make a
coffee company that's
is trying to earn the business of an
individual by going to them looking in
the eyes and being like hey man I have a
good coffee it tastes great would you
try it you do would you like it you
should buy from me whereas the Starbucks
approach being so large is more like
we have 300 million people in this
country if we if we if we change the
price in this way we'll increase by X
percent and all that stuff
it's all looked at by Numbers if we do a
pride campaign what's our what's our
risk assessment it's like we're going to
lose three percent here and four percent
there but gain six percent here and then
lose two percent there
yeah I don't care about any of that
stuff that that's the The Faceless sales
Act of the massive multinational
corporation
we want to be like hey why don't you
come hang out with us at our store yeah
we're like you should come and you
should like we should hang out and play
video games and like we want it to be
Community Based the the goal of the
coffee company is not just to sell bags
of coffee on the internet that's just
the start the goal is to create a
physical space where people can come and
communicate with like-minded people the
idea is you walk into a coffee shop for
your morning coffee and there are TVs
and those TVs are playing Tim cast
Stephen Crowder they're playing Ben
Shapiro and things like that so when the
average person is just walking by and
getting their coffee they are now a part
of this community too and welcome to the
conversation and for other people who
don't know who else agrees them or
doesn't and is scared you know that if
you come to a place like this most
people are going to agree with you yeah
and you're gonna be watching that show
and if they get mad about it they'll
leave but the average person's probably
going to be like he makes a good point
you can be like I do think he makes a
good point and then you'll talk with
like-minded people that's that's that's
the big vision for for doing coffee
because otherwise it's like
you know we could do a bunch of things
we could sell supplements we could sell
t-shirts whatever people are like why
coffee well the real reason is because
we want physical spaces and hanging out
having a cup of coffee is the place for
people to to do things and we want to
put up stages we're going to have comedy
we're going to have shows we want to we
want to bring back community and one of
the big things we want to do is Saturday
morning cartoons where parents will come
at seven seven a.m with their kids
cartoons will play that are approved
family friendly none of those weird
garbage and there will be pancake
sausage and eggs and whatever and the
parents can hang out and talk while the
kids hang out and play and that creates
communal bonds between people who are in
these local areas that's what I want to
do amazing that's why I'm pissed off
about what's going on in West Virginia
when I see them doing drag shows with
kids because that is
that is a problem but I will admit
I think that our mission in the long run
does away with that culturally by making
it Unthinkable you know like Ron Paul
said should abortion be illegal it
should be Unthinkable well some things
should be illegal some things should be
enforced but we will work to make it so
that certain things are Unthinkable and
we have a good family friendly Community
where people work for each other believe
in each other we respect individual
liberties and rights but we protect kids
from predators wow let's read more Super
chats
Gina Thomason says rumor has that Public
Square is coming after Amazon is that
true when take my money
I love it uh well we hope not to take
your money but we would love for the
businesses on the platform to take your
money certainly uh we are definitely
coming after Amazon that is our goal
that's where we're going that's
ultimately in the long run what we
aspire to do but not just by recreating
the wheel and doing it the same way
Amazon did it we actually have a few
really key differentiating factors for
example the small business point we're
talking about Amazon the way they've
structured it is that you only see the
mega corporate entities that they want
you to see that they have 30 rev share
deals with so you never actually get to
see organic small business uh exposure
the other thing that's different is
obviously that Amazon doesn't have any
local functionality you don't have an
ability to go pick up something from
your community or for that to default
there which is a primary difference that
we will always keep present uh the
future of Public Square similar to how
you're describing this is very Community
focused it has to be otherwise you're
not really scratching the itch if you
don't feel like you belong in a
community because you need trust in a
transaction you're not going anywhere so
we are definitely going after Amazon
we're actually going public so we can be
a company that's well funded Enough by
the people with some special protections
against activist investors which is
really exciting so that we can be by the
people for the people owned by we the
people and have that Capital to be able
to confront this this movement is very
expensive people don't realize that
Amazon has had billions of dollars to
play with and so we are going after
their power source we need people that
agree with the principles of Liberty and
the foundational values that this
country was built upon to actually shift
their dollars toward companies that
Embrace those values and that has to
also be capitalized the markets need to
be democratized where we the people
actually have investment opportunities
for people to pour money into because
right now in the investment world it's
dominated by ESG and Dei so from that
framework we are absolutely going after
Amazon and we got uh when are you going
public we expect to close here in the
next month or so it's really exciting to
to go public and go to the stock
exchange and everything yeah do the big
banner drop the whole nine wow yeah yeah
we're partnered in a SPAC transaction so
clbr and the New York Stock Exchange is
the SPAC we're partnered with
um so that's the company that we're
essentially taking over and then we're
we're the existing company in the stock
exchange from the rumble same way that
they went public so right dspac
transaction uh and it's an incredible
partnership and uh it's a like-minded
team that is wanting to take us public
and this will allow us to be a company
that's not just funded by Angel
Investors and and accredited ones which
I I love but are you a billionaire yet
no you're going to be about I'm very
poor you're gonna you're gonna be a
billion we're pouring everything into
the company when I when I look at this
and I look at Bud Light
the Bud Light effect proves what you're
doing is is needed and let me read the
Super Chat for you from uh camcam he
says my wife was about to buy a new
dress at Target after all of their pride
she went over to Public Square got a
whole new wardrobe let's go so it's
awesome the the stuff that we're seeing
this guy's complaining because you cost
him a lot I know I'm sorry Target was
supposed to save you money by that
boycott happening but here's what
happens first people say hey don't go to
Starbucks boycott Starbucks and they're
like where am I supposed to go yeah
exactly I gotta be honest like I went to
a small Cafe a local cafe because I was
like I'm not going to go to Starbucks
and I went in there and I was like I
would like a cold brew with heavy cream
and they went okay and then I kid you
not
the lady pours the coffee and then she
takes the coffee around like somewhat
behind the the counter where I can still
see her turns her back and does
something then walks back over with
coffee I look at him what that's half
and half and then she's like yeah and I
was like dude come on you could have
just told me you didn't have it yeah I
know that if I go to Starbucks they've
got everything and that's unfortunate
because I'm not a big fan I do like that
Starbucks is going the capitalist route
of being like hey we shouldn't do these
decorations anymore because our
customers getting pissed that's a good
thing so I'm of the mind to incentivize
corporations to do the good things so
I'm not anti-starbucks if they made that
move I think that's where you say like
hey Starbucks instead of they're all
striking and trying to take money away
from you I'm gonna keep giving you money
if you keep doing things that we like
but what we need is
what Public Square provides an actual
way to find what you're looking for when
you're used to these big corporations
like Target having what you need it's
it's hard to know how do you just go and
find something Public Square create that
directory now it was easy for this guy's
wife to go find a dress it's amazing
it's so good to hear another thing is
like all of the big corporations are
already fed right to you I mean if you
Google something or if you search for
something on the Internet it's probably
going to go through Google it's probably
going to be power down by Google and
it's probably going to give you an
option to buy it from Amazon
automatically without any kind of input
from you so the the ability to search is
a big deal you know yeah it's cool it
would be really cool if we get to the
point
where
the the businesses that are super
activisty
they're just it's getting to the point
where you're going to go you're going to
go on the app and you're going to find
most businesses being like we absolutely
agree with this because the average
person does and then you're going to
find these weirdo activist businesses
struggling and going out of business
like that one anti-cop Cafe in Seattle
was it oh yeah I can't remember where
they were they were like they were they
were they were saying deep on the police
or whatever and then they wouldn't allow
cops to even be served right and then
and then because of the crime they went
out of business yeah or something like
that there was a car dealership near us
that suddenly there were no cars and
when I looked it up it was like women
owned it's like this is a bad sign there
was a communist coffee shop in Toronto
where you could have your coffee free
and it was donation based and they
didn't last nine months but you're right
I mean part of our part of our goal too
is that uh what actually takes place is
a total transformative shift from
um corporate entities that have made a
Bad Bet on woke activism and ESG and Dei
and it actually totally dismantles those
philosophies because the goal too is
that those companies wake up and realize
like we took a Bad Bet this was a bad
move and the profits are moving not just
because people yelled at them but
because they actually move with their
feet and shifted their dollars elsewhere
So Stories like that are amazing thank
you for sharing that is absolutely the
goal yep all right let's grab some more
Super chats
neglectful sausage says imagine a steak
which not not only doesn't stop but
actively promotes child abusers who
touch kids and you sit here and do
nothing just go I'm outraged how is this
different you won't stop this right now
you're referring to me I'll tell you
what we're doing we we actually have
people reaching out to the attorney
general we are absolutely taking this
seriously where we have the ability to
do so I don't live in these other states
where this stuff's happening so what am
I supposed to do what am I doing in New
York well I don't know if it's directed
at you because like States like uh New
York with Kathy hokel and California are
doing enough damage on their own and
they have enormous populations I know
they lean blue but surely someone in
there should be trying to complain at
some point look I I went to the the
raps here in West Virginia and I was
like I find it absurd that blue states
have legalized social poker clubs but
West Virginia hasn't and they
immediately were like you're right let's
draft legislation and figure out how to
make social poker clubs the only reason
the action is being taken is because
someone has to go to them and say guys I
want action on this and they're gonna if
they agree they agree I I think is its
strong likelihood that um the people we
have reaching out to the local law
enforcement about these issues they're
going to be like you're completely
correct we're gonna we're gonna navigate
this what I believe will be likely to
happen is we'll probably get a state
level law specifically covering these
things instead of being like we're going
to apply what they're doing to an
existing law they'll probably want to
say let's from this point forward say we
put an end to it because that's
typically the easier legal thing to do
without starting a bunch of fights but
we'll see because I I think the laws
already have it but you'll get the
arguments like oh that that cohabitation
law is is ridiculous nobody would ever
enforce on something like that even
though it does cover open lewdness in
public
we'll see what happens
Nathan C says Karl Marx had an
incestuous relationship with his
daughter Evelyn she committed suicide
when he remarried his other children
died from neglect is that true
looks to filth I mean Phil's one was
always talking about marks you know the
philosophers well I didn't even hear
that I'm sorry what was that Karl Marx
had an incestuous relationship with his
daughter Evelyn uh there's there's a lot
of things about car marks that I've that
I've heard I've heard ancestral
incestuous relationships I've heard that
he had issues with like boils because he
didn't wash I heard he constantly was uh
asking for money from people these are
all things that I hear from people that
tend to not be partial towards Mark so I
don't know how accurate they are but I
mean they're fun to talk about all right
what is this uh Matthew says re Biden
CPAP I'm late 30s with CPAP needs to be
worn at night and during naps marks
disappear after a quick face wash this
is more than CPAP it could be that it's
just so old the market collagen to
bounce back yeah yeah but what I'm
saying is
because some people like no those straps
are CPAP straps yes I know they are my
point is they are trying to hide that
he's on oxygen I'm not saying he is an
oxygen I'm saying I don't believe them
they lie so often I would not be
surprised if they said look if we do the
typical method of putting the oxygen
tubing in then people are going to
notice yeah let's do a CPAP machine and
claim it's just a sleep apnea it's not a
big deal which this means it's applying
I know that photo was you know early in
the morning presumably it would be like
you weren't at night but then he has
these marks throughout the day then are
you implying that he's napping
throughout the day like that also
doesn't look good none of these options
are good the IV marks on his hand yeah
yeah I bet it's so much that it's
bruised stop uh once a week I bet well
remember during the debates they had the
remember you saw the the cord that came
out of his wrist remember this what was
it really yeah yeah yeah there was that
picture that got leaked of this little
coin it looked like a tube that was
coming out of his sleeve right here they
had him on an IV drip while he was
debating how else do you keep him awake
for two and a half hours
I bet I bet NAD I bet they're nicotine
yeah the IV treatments yeah so it's got
like B vitamins and stuff in it and
it's rejuvenating yeah amen it's
expensive a lot of people do tax dollars
Joe Rogan uh I don't think he does it
anymore he's now he takes the the nmn I
I think I I I someone told me he
mentioned on his show that doesn't do
anything but he used to do uh uh I think
Charlie Kirk swears by it as well yep I
think no Biden's doing it I think Hunter
gives 10 of his crack cocaine to the big
guy while he's sitting next to him
he's dead for the big guy
all right all right we got we got uh one
more here one more here Samurai EAC says
I got my company on Public Square we're
the largest direct to civilian body
armor manufacturer in the U.S we changed
the market our company mission is to
glorify the Christ by equipping the free
man of the United States with tools of
Liberty wow what a mission statement I
feel like these men have so much fun
writing these mission statements like
they're powerful they're cool yeah when
we were writing this I was like we need
to we need to like hit these points like
this is what this is what it's all about
all right everybody if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
this show with your friends and go over
to timcast.com click join us because the
members only show is going to be silly
spicy and not so family friendly and
that'll be up in a few minutes you can
follow the show at timcast IRL you can
follow me at timcast Michael do you want
to shout anything out head to
publicesq.com we'd love it if you join
the community it's free we'll never ask
you for money we're just going to show
you lots of awesome businesses that
don't hate you of all different
Industries so we'd love it if you join
us there thanks for having me actually
businesses that like you businesses that
like you yes it's really refreshing not
everybody hates us we have a whole
community of folks that don't so right
on it's pretty awesome are you on the
internet do you want people to follow
you uh I'm on Twitter Instagram real
Michael seif seif the first four letters
of my last name on Twitter and then at
real Michael Seifert on Instagram but
yeah public sq.com you'll see I'm not
that interesting but our company is so
check us out
I'm a writer for timcast.com you should
follow at timcast news on Twitter and
Instagram as you heard tonight you can
you can see our on the ground reporting
and see stories from me from Chris
Bertman from a bunch of other great
people
um I did uh I recorded with Sheamus for
two hours today for his podcast shamers
it's on Rumble at the end of it he told
me uh you make me want to rethink the
First Amendment so I think that's
interesting go watch it tomorrow uh
that's a heck of a tease yeah like uh I
don't know man I I think I'm interesting
on Rebel no I'm just kidding uh if you
want to follow me personally you can
follow me on Instagram at handclare.b
and on Twitter at HC bromel thank you so
much
I am Phil Labonte I am Phil that remains
on Twitter Phil that remains official on
Instagram the band is All That Remains
available on Spotify Pandora Apple music
on YouTube all the things
and I'm search.com that was a good one
guys always good to see you Michael good
to see you thank you yeah let's uh get
to the after show we will see you all
over at timcast.com in a couple minutes
thanks for hanging out